Maria Delgado tumbled through the air
the Furious sea wind whipped all around
her her hair blew in her eyes trying to
Shield them from the view of what was
rapidly coming to hit her Square in the
face an ocean as black as the night sky
she barely had a second to brace herself
before splash the impact in the cold
knocked all the air out of her a flurry
of bubbles disappeared into the darkness
as she sank further and further down not
knowing which way was up Maria kicked
frantically as her water logged clothes
dragged her back her head found the
surface and she barely had a moment to
gasp in half a lung full of air before a
wave hit her in the side of the head
knocking her back under kicking and
spluttering she managed to poke her head
up again and tried to wave desperately
at the metal Behemoth looming over her
the cruise ship that had felt so safe
and warm now looked like a cliff face
the lowest window that she could see was
more than 100 ft above her head there
had been music playing on the deck but
she was so far below now that she
couldn't even hear it anymore all she
could hear was the rumbling of the
engines and an ominous swishing chopping
sound behind her Maria's stomach dropped
she felt the ocean pulling at her a
current forcing her beneath the waves
she had fallen off the back of the
cruise ship and that meant the current
gripping her and turning her beneath the
water she tumbled and twisted in the
darkness feeling all of the air rushing
out of her lungs again squinting as best
as she could through the stinging
saltwater she saw the thing that she'd
been dreading an enormous propeller each
Blade the size of her house spinning and
spinning just on the edge of her vision
and gliding steadily towards her the
water was sucking her towards it pulling
her faster and faster she'd never been a
very strong swimmer but there wasn't
time to feel bad about that now she
needed to escape anyway way she could
desperately lashing at the water Maria
kicked and clawed herself out of the
current she had to swim sideways as fast
as she could otherwise she didn't want
to think about it the propellers were
getting closer getting larger in the
water the awful sound of their approach
didn't just shake the water around her
it shook all of the water inside of her
making her stomach turn in fear she
hadn't breathed in in a long time her
body was going into shock from the cold
everything around her was doing its best
to drag her down to a slow icy death or
maybe a fast painful death from the
impact of several tons of spinning steel
something hard and fast crunched into
Maria's heel moving so quickly that it
sent her spinning through the water the
propeller had hit her its next
Revolution passed about a foot in front
of her face before the turbulence of the
cruise ship's wake took hold of her and
threw her away then all of a sudden
fresh air was hitting her face the water
had lifted her up to the surface and
carried her in the foamy wake that
stretched away from the cruise ship
already the metal Juggernaut was a
couple of hundred ft away from her but
she tried to swim after it the currents
in the water would only carry her
further backward Maria had no choice but
to tread water and stare as the cruise
ship that had once been so large and
imposing above her steadily became a DOT
on the horizon and then disappeared
entirely her husband had been in bed she
had just stepped out onto the deck to
have some fresh air he could sleep
through anything chances are he wouldn't
notice she was missing until he woke up
in the morning and who knew what time
that would be they were on vacation and
he hadn't set an alarm he would probably
assume that she'd gone for an early
breakfast without him only once he'd sat
down and finished his breakfast and gone
back to the room to find she was still
missing would he start to worry by that
point she would have stopped kicking
hours ago she wasn't sure how deep the
ocean was out here how many minutes
would it take for her body to sink to
the bottom or or would it take hours
perhaps her corpse wouldn't even be
halfway down to the seabed by that point
she was shivering so violently that she
was struggling to keep herself above the
surface her legs weren't kicking like
they would in a pool they were spasming
and tensing up her clothes ballooned all
around her doing nothing but get in the
way as she tried desperately to stay
alive she had no phone it had fallen off
the deck with her now likely on its own
way down to the seafloor she had no
light not nothing air in her lungs to
cry for help and no one between herself
and the Horizon to hear this was it this
was how she would die a sense of morbid
curiosity filled her what exactly was
below her maybe there was a reef
somewhere down where her corpse could
lie peacefully what she saw when she
stuck her head beneath the surface was
Darkness swirling and empty and
painfully cold except there was
something else moving down there the B
small smaller than she was some kind of
sea creature swimming up to meet her
Maria lifted her head took a deep breath
andam down towards it it wasn't swimming
like a usual fish its shadowy silhouette
seemed to Ripple and twist as her eyes
slowly adjusted to the darkness she saw
what it was a squid maybe a meter in
length at least she wouldn't be dying
alone out here the squid started to swim
faster approaching her quickly at that
moment she suddenly remembered some of
the things she' heard about squids
weren't they Hunters she had seen a
nature documentary once where sperm
whales had come up from the seabed with
enormous gouges around their eyes from
where they'd been attacked by a school
of squids suddenly Maria didn't want her
companion anymore but it was too late
the squid had almost reached her end she
felt her mind starting to float out of
itself her eyes weren't focusing
properly the squid wasn't just swimming
towards her it was flashing almost like
a strobe light different lurd colors
filled the ocean around her and it
convulsed in different colors until all
of a sudden it wasn't a small squid at
all anymore it ballooned in size
swelling and bulging all around her
enormous tentacles unfurled themselves
and whipped at the water all around her
it was 10 m tall now 20 40 70 the squid
seemed to fill the whole ocean
swallowing up all of the available water
and leaving her in a tiny puddle
floating just a few feet away from its
gashing beak some of the tentacles
didn't even look like tentacles anymore
they had turned into Pinchers or even
human looking arms and legs except the
fingers were tipped with grotesque
Talons she had to escape had to get away
if Maria had thought she'd swam fast to
get away from the cruise ship's
propellers it was nothing compared to
how fast she swam now without care for
her trembling limbs struggling lungs or
rapidly fading Consciousness Maria knew
she had to get away from this
monstrosity there was no hope for her
without escape the flashing lights felt
like they were all around her no matter
which way she swam it just felt like
they were getting brighter and brighter
until a pair of hands grabbed her and
lifted her out of the water Maria kicked
and screamed trying to fight the
tenacles off but they pinned her down to
the deck and held her there voices
surrounded her bright lights shining in
her face this was how she would die
until a shadow blocked out one of the
lights and her eyes managed to focus on
something it was a man he was talking to
her in another language desperately
trying to calm her down where was the
squid what had happened to it Maria
lashed out with her limbs trying to
shake herself free from the fishermen
who were holding her down on the deck
she threw her gaze sideways and saw an
enormous net lifting a school of fish
out of the water there were hundreds of
them all thrashing and slapping against
one another and there poking out of the
bottom of the net was a single tentacle
dread filled her stomach but her body
body gave out on her and she fell
unconscious all right run it one more
time Dr Matthews sat at the laptop and
watched the grainy CCTV footage for what
felt like the H 100th time it was
footage from a fishing vessel captured
off the coast of Sagal the first 30
seconds of the clip just showed the view
from the front of the boat waves
splashing here and there but mostly
Darkness then all of a sudden there were
two shapes moving through the water one
was a terrified woman desperately
swimming towards the surface the other
shape was harder to pin down when
Matthews had first watched the video
she'd seen a colossal sea creature
writhing beneath the surface but each
time that she'd watched it since the
creature seemed to get a bit smaller and
lose some of its sting perhaps the shock
of what she was seeing had just been
wearing off regardless it was time to do
the mandatory checks before the latest
SCP was brought into the facility Dr
Matthews walked through the corridors of
the containment facility and came to the
large double doors that led into the
main hanger it had been hard to find a
facility large enough to contain this
SCP they knew it was capable of reaching
enormous sizes so they had to construct
an aquarium big enough to house it at
its maximum size Dr Matthews started
walking across the walkway it hung
suspended over the reinforced aquarium
and would be strictly off limits once
the SCP had been moved into the facility
it was far too easy for the squid to
Simply grab a member of staff and pull
them beneath the water was heading
towards the control panel at the other
side the tank was 150 M cubed and so
walking the length of it took her well
over a minute this was by far the
biggest containment she'd ever been
involved with in terms of scale as well
as severity the logistics and trying to
organize the containment of this squid
had run into the millions of dollars and
were still going up every day it had
taken her and her research team a while
to convince the board that this SCP
posed a significant enough threat to
warrant the investment she needed to
make sure not to screw it up guards
stood all around the perimeter of the
tank holding b74 Harpoon guns with
electrified discharge shafts looking
down into the water Dr Matthews could
see the 15 depth charges all hanging at
various Heights throughout the tank each
of these depth charges were wirelessly
connected to a computer that monitored
the Integrity of the glass all around
the tank if the SCP were to make even
the slightest crack in the glass all 15
depth charges were to be set off
simultaneously she hoped that was enough
to kill it God help her if it wasn't it
would keep one entity here for study but
she had reason to believe that there
were more of them all over the world and
so preparations were in place to arm a
team that could scour the oceans and
eliminate any others that were found
today was the day SCP 252 the humbled
squid was about to arrive the shipping
container was lifted by a crane and
carried to the right spot somewhere
inside it was a large sealed tank of
water holding an instance of SCP 252
that would drop the shipping container
into the reinforced aquarium and let it
sink all the way to the bottom before
detonating remote charges on its doors
and on the sealed tank inside allowing
SCP 252 to escape and fill its new
enclosure Dr Matthews stood with her
hand shaking over the button it was now
or never taking a deep breath she
pressed it down firmly and watched on
the security camera monitor as several
puffs of bubbles Rose from the container
and the doors swung open none of them
could see inside the container they just
had to wait then all of a sudden a small
shape darted out it was Tiny no more
than a meter in length what had happened
to the reports that this thing was 75 M
across Dr Matthews looked around at her
co-workers in shock she didn't expect to
see a monster to unfur itself out of the
container and grow larger and larger but
all that had emerged was a tiny little
black squid but none of her colleagues
looked back at her all of them were
staring wide-eyed at the security feed
Matthews glanced back and saw that the
little squid was flashing various colors
as it swam around just like the CCTV
footage that she had been studying for
the prior few weeks a scream filled the
room and was quickly answered with
another as her fellow researchers ran
away from what they were seeing
terrified by the shapes on the screen
Matthews just looked back and forth in
confusion the Colossal sea monster that
had been reported to her wasn't there
there was just a tiny squid flashing
various colors what were all of them so
afraid of and now would she break it to
her boss that she'd spent millions of
dollars on a giant aquarium loaded with
depth charges for a squid the size of a
large dog 2 weeks later she found
herself attempting to do just that
standing in front of the disciplinary
panel Dr Matthews tried to explain what
had happened SCP 252 the humbled squid
is suspected to be the origin of a lot
of myths surrounding giant squids and
perhaps even the Kraken itself when
hunting all the squids pre attempts to
flee by the most direct path possible
overcome with Terror at what they were
seeing the squid can appear to be
anywhere between 50 and 75 m in size
with up to 200 appendages growing from
its mantle these appendages can all take
various forms often depending on what
the prey is most afraid of for example a
test subject who is terrified of spiders
will see the hairy legs of a tarantula
amongst the tentacles but C is the
important word here because while SCP
252 appears to take on its form the
reality is that these are all
hallucinations brought on by viewing the
Squid's rapidly flashing colors while
hunting SCP 252 rapidly Cycles its
chromatophores which results in powerful
hallucinations all prey will then
immediately lay down their defenses and
try to flee as quickly as possible
leaving them open to being eaten by the
relatively small and weak real squid
however as Dr Matthews had discovered it
was possible to inoculate yourself
against these Effects by viewing the
grainy CCTV footage from the fishing
boat on repeat so many times in the
runup to SCP 22's arrival Dr Matthews
had built up a kind of immunity allowing
her to see the SCP as it actually was
even though her colleagues ran away in
Terror one fun fact Dr Matthews said is
that the prey will attempt to
rationalize the scp's size even when it
is in a confined space that's impossibly
small so if you were taking a bath with
the squid you would somehow believe that
the squid was both 75 M large and fully
submerged in the tub in your guest
bathroom funny isn't it none of the
disciplinary board members had a word
they all stared at her in bamus silence
please don't fire me you edge the
poolside chlorine stench air filling
your nose the sound of splashing and
lifeguards whistling bouncing off the
indoor pool pool facility walls the
water ripples family and friends egging
you to cannonball in the pool almost
beckoning you to jump with its
suggestive waves yet there remains an
underlying fear one that brings your
hands to your face and causes your teeth
to chatter even as the pool clear as
glass with chlorine hides no secrets a
monster some teeth nashing Megalodon
ascending from the depths of Extinction
Leviathan curling its Barbed tail to
strike its prey at any moment or even
some vast unknowable Force ancient as
Earth hardly comprehensible to human
Minds waiting dreaming to breach the
surface no matter what form this
gargantuan invisible monster takes you
know one thing once you jump in you will
not return to shore you take a moment
recompose yourself and laugh off the
fear maybe a product of too much
research on the bloop that deep ocean
sound continuing to confound scientists
as to its cause or maybe too much
binging infographics videos on sea
monsters Krakens and Lochness monsters
mysterious globsters cast onto Shores
throughout America whatever the origin
the thought seems ridiculous to you now
and your fears regarding invisible
sharks stalking the pool perimet
Escape your mind as you hurl yourself
into the water SCP 1128 in the vast
archives of a hidden sight stuffed into
a drawer amongst uncountable Horrors
like it the SCP Foundation holds a
description of a vast unfathomable
horror that'll make you more suspicious
the next time you pass a pool lake or
even a bathtub or puddle of water SCP
1128 is a gigantic aquatic monster
lurking in waters unknown and that's all
the foundation will let anyone not
assigned to testing know about it while
the foundation has never shed away from
those Moby Dicks of the deep including
the several thousand kilm long arthropod
SCP 169 and has even utilized such
predators in the past for their own
benefit like the lengthy Beast SCP 3000
SCP 1128 poses a unique challenge anyone
who knows of its description be on
surface level details will fall under
the anomaly's effect the representation
you seen now is merely an artist's
interpretation of the basic prompt the
foundation of course had to discover the
monster's effects in the first place the
chain of communication becomes foggy but
a tip from an unknown source alerted the
foundation to the monster's existence
and details regarding its manifestation
one man who had stumbled upon the
entity's full description started
developing acute th glossophobia the
fear of large bodies of water not Bodies
In The Water mind you the man refused to
relax on the beach or fly overseas
claiming he could see the monster's dark
silhouette lurking underwater ever
scouting for him this eventually
extended to even closed bodies of water
like lakes ponds and pools still
insisting that the creature swam under
the surface trailing him wherever he
went his friends dismissed him as crazy
and he too believed he had fallen under
some hysteria he decided to take a nice
warm bath to soothe his mind and ease
his troubles he turned on the faucet and
let the tub fill up he put on his best
bathing suit ready to calm his anxiety
once and for all this had been plaguing
his mind for far too long and he was
ready to rid all the negativity
surrounding this phobia basically he was
sick and tired of being sick and tired
over the idea of it all he mustered up
the Cur courage and with the
anticipation to just simply relax he
took his first confident step into the
tub he paused for a moment and breathed
a sigh of relief he picked up his other
foot and stepped fully into the bath
Splash he fell straight down right
through the tub waves and Bubbles
blocked his vision his arms flailed as
he sunk deeper into an abyss of water
and fear this wasn't supposed to happen
he thought several moments later while
still in a full-on panic the boyancy of
his body began to slow his sinking the
bubbles from his underwater screams Rose
above him and he began to follow their
Direction scrambling back up to where
he'd come just as he made it back to the
surface of the tub water choking and
hyperventilating in Terror he swore he
could see a distant creature the very
same that stalked him through oceans and
pools staring at him shaking he hoisted
himself out of the water and ran out of
the house hysterical he ran through the
surrounding in neighborhood desperately
searching for someone he could relay his
experience to Blinded By fear he
neglected to spot a puddle in the middle
of the road he ran on he raised his foot
arched forward and landed straight into
the seemingly shallow water splash again
he found himself completely submerged
and drowning after a minute he did
emerge from the puddle but not in one
piece knowledgeable of this incident the
foundation set about expunging any
traces of the monster's description from
the world physical and digital the
description had low distribution
according to the results of foundation
web crawlers but this hardly stopped the
foundation's Endeavor with Forum posts
deleted individuals located and
amnestied and cataloges trolled to
ensure the description did not
proliferate the foundation engaged in
what it does best questionably ethical
experiments first they had an anonymous
d-class uninformed of the creatures
effect read the description of the Beast
while the pamphlet they gave him
confused him somewhat he didn't feel
particularly frightened by The Entity
and he confusedly put on the diving suit
the foundation testers provided him as
they connected him to a cable and told
him to enter a bathtub the declass did
as they instructed him the d-class
expressed initial confusion at the tub's
depth remarking that it looks so tiny
from the outside as the declass
continued to descend he analyzed his
surroundings realizing the not reality
that enveloped him he asked how an ocean
got stuffed into a bathtub but the test
organizer had no room for miscellaneous
talk he continued to descend until he
hit the Sandy Bottom seaweed covering
the ocean floor the declass looked
around tropical fish swam in schools
Coral covered the seabed and to his
right dropped an immense Cliff a sheer
Edge the test organizer advised the
declass to approach the cliff and he
begrudging ly complied as he struggled
in his diving suit he fell back and
screamed SCP 1128 The Aquatic horror
swam distantly gracefully even and paid
no attention to the d-class so fixated
upon it he realized that the creature
matched the one he read on the pamphlet
and almost complained about this when he
saw a blue whale swimming alongside SCP
1128 compared to the monster the whale
looked like a guppy the whale glided in
front of SCP 112 G's Jaws the monster
remained tranquil stared at its prey and
bit the whale in two with one cha its
teeth glistened in the water the test
operator requested the declass to pull
back and as the cable began to draw him
toward where he came declass stared at
the creature swallowing the chunks of
whale whole the DCL class's eyes
remained fixated on the creature
partially INF fright partially in awe he
wondered how ocean trollers hadn't
discovered such a giant Beast yet with
the world effectively under 100%
surveillance something the d-class knew
far too well as a convict yet the
d-class recognized and if not
comprehended partially understood the
ocean's vastness and mystery the dark
depths reveal no inkling as to their
contents and a creature like a giant
squid or the cican can remain in hiding
for centuries if not Millennia it held
him in wondrous thought to consider the
fastness of the depths when SCP 1128
stopped and stared at the declass this
feeling of Wonder was quickly replaced
with fear as the creature approached the
d-class pleaded with the test operators
for help as the test operators
accelerated the rate of the cable
returning the d-class took short shallow
breaths filling his body with dangerous
nitrogen as he ascended further
impairing his judgment he had devolved
into gibberish and screaming when face
to face the monster consumed its prey
the cable went slack and the test
operator pulled up only a broken wire
snap the water turning a cloudy red the
test operator knew that the unprotected
d-class had no chance at survival
against the monster but he could
potentially arm and shield them he had
another similarly ignorant declass once
again dress in a scuba suit and enter
the tub however the test operator placed
the d-class within a shark cage allow
the movie Jaws and lowered the cage in
with another cable and winch system
while Unsure how this would Faire with
SCP 1128 the test operator remained
hopeful that the d-class could survive
and recount his story unfortunately as
the cage lowered into the tub the test
operator received no response from the
d-class until the line spontaneously
tightened snapped and loosened hoping to
find the DCL class's Remains the test
operator only found shredded pieces of
metal torn and twisted like taffy the
test operator decided that he could
utilize the foundation's Arsenal to his
advantage and used an anomalously
toughened shark cage in his testing
perhaps using an anomaly like the
Clockwork machine SC SCP 914 he gained
approval from his high-ups to undergo
this procedure and after some testing
behind a shining strong as titanium
shark cage which he placed another
d-class within hoping for a success with
the monster however proved
unsatisfactory as the same thing
happened as the previous test only
without any sour of metallic remains
while bitter that the monster had won
again he wondered where the cage had
landed meanwhile Foundation forces
labored tirelessly to find SCP 1128
location hoping to avoid any civilian
contact with the creature luckily a GPS
signal established itself upon the most
recent d-class test with the tracking
device on the d-class signifying the
monster's General location the
foundation had redacted the location of
the monster perhaps in a vain attempt to
hide a very very near threat from
potential readers the foundation set up
a team of only the most talented boers
in its forces mobile Containment Force
Kappa 12 sea Devils upon arriving at the
location the sea Devils discovered the
previously enhanced shark cage
completely undamaged however closer
inspection revealed traces of human DNA
on the bars though the foundation could
not confirm whether the DNA belonged to
the previously sent d-class the test
operator while glad his shark cage
survived the monster's attack still
found himself dissatisfied with the
overall results of the test he knew he
needed to quell this creature's impact
before a large population viewed it or
knew of it the horrible Beast had evaded
all attempts at peaceful interaction
perhaps with a Madness not unlike
Captain Ahab yearning for the death of
his white whale the test operator armed
a d-class with a specialized weapon
designed to deal with aquatic threats
promptly this weapon potentially another
of the foundation's precious Arsenal
could potentially harm if not kill the
creature while he knew the foundation's
mission statement forbade unnecessary
destruction the test operator felt it
may turn necessary if matters turn any
worse thus he sent his armed declass
through the tub once more ready to
engage the beast in combat the attempt
as one may expect did not last long the
d-class upon spotting the creature aimed
his weapon at the monster and attacked
it but rather than drive the creature
away it only turned intently upon the
d-class as if it desired a fight the
d-class barely managed to scrape SCP
1128 before the creature devoured the
d-class leaving the test operator once
again empty-handed defeated and without
any more resources to deal with the
Beast the test operator ceased his
attempts at vesting the creature and
followed the foundation's more cautious
approach expunging any publicly found
descriptions of SCP 1128 as needed and
diverting any vessels away from the
anomaly's exclusion Zone as maintained
by the Sea Devils while the creature had
proven treacherous in unexpected
situations prior engulfing the man who
first heard the creature's description
in a rain puddle researchers could
hardly expect what would transpire a
d-class Afflicted with the monster's
effect and observed for testing avoided
all bodies of water as required
eventually however the d-class needed to
interact with some kind of water
drinking water in a choice between
little water exposure or certain death
the d-class felt inclined to choose the
former he filled his cup with water and
for fun placed his finger into the cup
dropping it into the water as CP 1128
unseen from the outside violently pulled
the declass through the cup into its
watery domain the d-class had not a
chance to scream this alarmed
containment staff now cognizant that
even the tiniest specks of water could
transport an Afflicted person into scp1
28's ocean territory this proved
particularly strenuous when a new report
of a potential SCP 1128 manifestation
arose an old woman isolated with her
cats and knitting supplies found an
article online with a description of the
monster frightened and disgusted by what
she read she closed the article and
continued on with her monotonous life
such a life would take a turn for the
worst however when she too developed
that all-encompassing water-based fear
her apartment over looked an outdoor
pool and one day looking outside she
swore she could see that same dark
silhouette as the man did lurking in the
water among kids and parents playing she
swiftly closed the window curtains and
taped the seam shut allowing no light to
peek through eventually this paranoia
affected her hygiene neglecting showers
and baths for fear of the creature's
wrath she swore she could see the
silhouette in any individual droplet of
water her skin began to flake as she
avoided water as much as humanly
possible cracks developing on her arms
legs and face inflaming into rashes and
itches her scratching further increased
the flaking she even eliminated water
from her diet sealing the faucets with
duct tape and consuming exclusively
orange juice she threw out her cat's
water bowls dehydrating them they
pleaded with her as she continued to
devolve avoiding any contact with the
outside world even as it attempt Ed to
contact her eventually a concerned
neighbor contacted the local police
concerning the situation and the case
caught the foundation's radar
recognizing the symptoms of a potential
SCP 1128 infection a mobile task force
disguised themselves as civilians to
enter the apartment building and
potentially interfere with the woman's
condition they entered the complex
climbing up the stairs with barraging
equipment for forced entry as would
prove necessary to use to enter the
woman's apartment she had nailed the
door shut with wood and sealed the
cracks along the sides with plaster in
an attempt to keep out any water vapor
she had similarly blocked the window
with wood planks a horrid meia Asma of
dead skin and citrus filled the
apartment the old woman soaking it in
ever avoiding the dreaded monster the
foundation task force attempted peaceful
entry knocking on the door and asking if
anyone lived in the apartment the woman
couldn't speak if she wanted to her
throat had dried to near silence save a
croak suddenly the task force and the
woman heard a rumbling noise outside
thunder rain the woman panicked and
yelped don't come in here in a froggy
voice the task force eventually decided
they needed to use their equipment and
entered via barrage the door collapsed
and an immediate densed air clogged the
task Force's sight blinding and choking
them the woman shrieked and backed
against the window inadvertently the
task force insisted they were here to
help the woman but she simply heaved
heavily saying something unintelligible
in that dry cracking voice the rain
began pounding on the window patter
patter patter as the task force
attempted to gain hold of the woman she
resisted their movements moving around
the room while the task force
intentionally avoided violent
confrontation the rain grew in its
intensity as the woman continued running
around her apartment tripping over her
starved cats eventually she fell back
onto the window at which the boards
blocking it fell onto the floor exposing
the pouring rain fully she screamed as
she saw the silhouette of the monster
staring at her in every individual
raindrop one drop landed on her skin and
she violently vanished pulled into a
minuscule Speck of water the task force
collapsed from exhaustion perhaps
dreading their inevitable amnestic
treatment following exposure with an S
SCP 1128 afflect yet they couldn't help
but wonder what the old woman saw in a
single single Speck of water that could
cause that degree of fear and paranoia
the kind of fear only caused by entire
oceans condensed into a single droplet
besides the monster what else did she
see in those multitude of droplets the
fish that populated the sea the whale
carcasses left behind by SCP 1128 the
sea Devils viewed from below Drifting On
The Water unsuspecting just as one may
view a grain of sand and see the Sahara
she too saw that raindrop and viewed an
ocean entire along with whatever
malevolent creatures inhabited one may
have more Sympathy for the child
reluctant to jump into the pool water
knowing not necessarily that something
inhabits that body of water but that the
body belongs to a cycle much larger than
itself larger than any sea or Ocean and
the only thing that can Traverse that
cycle is a monster a creature like SCP P
1128 the task force went back to their
local site to report what happened
during the incident like so many
incidents the foundation deals with the
sum total of those that risk their lives
for the greater good is a couple memory
erasing syringes and another update to
documentation a description of SCP 1128
remains in the stuffy Locker lurking in
weight among other horrifying stories in
the SCP databases Sea Of Terror just
like that test operator that attempted
to best the monster could the
foundation's attempts ever surmount the
possibility of another person being
Afflicted could they conquer the sea in
a member of that task Force's dreams
they perceive a dark blue ocean and the
distant black shadow that resides within
and from this ocean they can view the
bathtubs sinks pools puddles cups of
water and Rain droplets of the world
seen from Below although they know not
what SC SCP 1128 looks like they too
experience the fear it summons among
those that do the paranoia the fear
although it may not manifest directly in
people's lives it can always be observed
stalking waiting lurking under a murky
surface watching with hidden
eyes imagine this your researcher with
an interest in and an aptitude for or
marine biology over the years your work
has taken you far and wide to the
furthest corners of the Earth's oceans
you've observe countless species of sea
life from fish and Crustaceans to whales
and sharks predators and prey alike
during one of your travels you find
yourself off the coast of South Africa
monitoring the local population of sea
creatures looking out across the water
you see a large dark shape moving below
the surface there is a shadow Street
waking its way towards Your Vessel Dark
As night speeding Like a Torpedo you
rush across the deck leaning over the
port side as the shape swims Beneath
Your Boat you're certain you know what
it was after all your years studying the
world beneath the waves you know a whale
shark when you see one the largest known
species of fish still in existence the
whale shark is a filter feeder
consisting on a diet of Plankton and
other tiny aquatic organisms a whale
shark poses absolutely no threat to
humans or rather any whale shark other
than this one would impose a threat but
how could you know that scanning the
water you strain your eyes trying to
spot what you assumed was an ordinary
whale shark swimming below but there is
nothing no sign of it anywhere sighing
you think you've might have missed your
chance to see one in the wild perhaps it
changed Direction instead of swimming
under the boat you tell yourself the
ship turns and starts making its way
back towards the small Harbor leaving
you blissfully unaware that there's an
extra passenger on board as you
disembark you notice something on the
side of the boat emblazoned on the hole
is a motif of a familiar shape a whale
shark depicted entirely in painted dots
you stare at it for a moment intrigued
by the pattern it reminds you of a piece
you once saw an Aboriginal Australian
style of dot art you're a little taken
about by The Coincidence having briefly
spotted a whale shark while out at Sea
earlier blissfully unaware that this
painting marks your first encounter with
SCP
1449 known more colloquially as the
dream time whale shark in fact you're so
amused by seeing the whale shark earlier
only to find one painted here on the
boat that it distracts you you don't
realize that the whale shark painting
hadn't been on the side of the boat when
you'd shipped out instead you pay the
crew and thank the captain for letting
you hire The Vessel for your research
and then head off by the time you make
it back to the nearby town and settle
down in after after a long day on the
water the dotted painting of the whale
shark has already slipped from your
mind but as you begin drifting off and
everything goes dark you're about to
find out that your encounter with the
Dreamtime whale shark is only just
beginning you've never been a heavy
sleeper and rarely remember your dreams
any that you might have seem to pass out
of your head the moment you wake up or
are too faint for you to acknowledge
while you're sleeping but tonight is
different tonight you're dreaming
vividly in this dream water surrounds
you like it has your whole career but
this time you're underneath the surface
a drift in an empty ocean nothing around
you but endless blank sea you feel
something in your hand something smooth
and moving gently like organic matter
something alive you find yourself
gripping the tail of a whale shark and
somehow as is often the way with dreams
you know that this is the same whale
shark from earlier that
day the one that swam up to your boat
and ended up sticking on the side of it
as a DOT art painting SCP 1449 has this
latent ability while it normally appears
as a flat two-dimensional piece of
Aboriginal Australian dot art the
Dreamtime whale shark can shift whenever
it is underwater it still appears as a
collection of painted dots in this
unmistakable shape of a whale shark but
in an aquatic environment it becomes
three-dimensional and that's what you'd
seen swimming towards the boat not just
a whale shark but SCP
1449 within your dream you release the
Dreamtime whale shark's tail and begin
to float
upwards breaking the surface of the
water you breathe lungfuls of fresh air
the first thing you see is land and it's
close by close enough for you to swim to
shore paddling through the water you
reach an island one in a chain of small
land masses tiny continents in a shallow
unfamiliar ocean you look back to the
water but can find no sign of SCP 1449
the Dreamtime whale shark has brought
you here and left you on this island but
you can only speculate as to why there
must be a reason you insist to yourself
the Dreamscape around you it would seem
is either the creation of SCP 1449 or at
the very least a side effect of falling
asleep close by to where you saw the
Dreamtime whale shark in its painted
form whatever this place is there must
be some some way to uncover an answer it
stands to reason you think that if you
can understand what's going on then
perhaps therein lies the key to escaping
this dream and waking up back in
reality the small island you find
yourself on and the others nearby are
inhabited by strange life forms as you
walk across the shore sand clinging to
your wet feet you approach what you
thought at a distance to be a group of
other people instead you see a group of
peculiar beings they are not quite human
but they are definitely close the closer
you walk you notice these strange
humanoid shapes huddle tighter together
their backs to you when you try to call
out to them asking where you are or how
you might return to reality they bustle
away the wind carries the sound of their
chatter towards you and you're certain
you hear them call you another one just
another traveler from afar what you
don't realize lost in this dream
environment is that there are others
like it pocket worlds like this one
similar but different currently being
experienced by any others asleep near
SCP
1449 as you Ponder what to do on the
beach the captain of the boat you hired
is on a different version of the same
island watching a herd of multiple 2,000
kilo platypi being shepherded by six
tattooed 3 m tall humanoid figures
meanwhile his first m is in another
version of this dream world learning how
to hunt under the tutelage of a man
called gray the rabbit Hunter each
version of SCP 1449 Dreamscape have
separate continuities to each other they
are differing copies of the same chain
of islands with the same inhabitants but
each visited by a different traveler
from afar in their sleep much like a
lucid dream visitors to the dream time
whale sharks worlds can interact with
them shaping and altering events in the
continuity they find themselves in
deciding to leave the beach you would
like to make your way towards Higher
Ground to try try to get a wider scope
of your surroundings fortunately there
is a towering mountainous shape nearby
standing like dark serrated teeth
against the clear Horizon you begin your
dangerous track ascending your way up
these dead Jagged Hills you're still
unclear on how you got here or how to
escape but you will yourself to keep
climbing knowing there must be some way
to wake up from this bizarre dream
finally reaching level ground you take a
moment to catch your breath collecting
your thoughts before advancing any
further you turn gazing out over the
landscape spreading out below and all
around you the island is small enough
you can see the shore where you arrived
and the ocean flanking this land mass on
all sides in this short moment you
appreciate the beauty of this bizarre
Dream World for the first time the trees
Sway in the gentle breeze moving like
the calm rolling of waves in the water
Beyond both glistening with the warm
light of the sun well it is still true
that you have no idea how or why SCP
1449 brought you here or how to leave
you think to yourself that at least this
dream environment isn't a hostile one
not that you'd want to be stranded there
forever but there are certainly far more
unforgiving places one can dream about a
grim thought suddenly Dawns on you how
long have you been here does time pass
differently in this world to the one
you're still asleep in a sound shakes
your thoughts back to your current here
and now it was was a voice you're sure
of it a voice calling out but not to you
traversing the dead Jagged Hills you see
a figure a person from The Real World
like you not one of the local humanoids
they don't see you they're calling out
to someone in a ramshackle Hut Cobble
together from pieces of wood and other
scraps on the arm of the figure's dark
military-like uniform is a symbol and
you can just make out three distinct
letters s c p a wooden plank that
functioned as the door creaked open
revealing a second figure the man looks
disheveled his worn clothing patched
with scraps of leather and shark skin
making him looked as cobbled together as
his makeshift hun like he was an
extension of the small structure he
watch as the man talks to the agent
overhearing his words don't say anything
if you say anything I lose my mind you
can say anything and something horrible
happens the strange man warns talking
too quickly for the foundation agent to
reply you're a dreamer like me my name
is Nikolai I am the ship Seer of the dun
and the Brotherhood of
sikin the man Nikolai he called himself
seemed distressed tripping over his
words disagreeing with himself until he
starts trailing off into swearing
obscenities I'm not Nikolai he shouts I
am anent anent John before stumbling and
cursing again I'm sorry I can't can't
keep the memory straight being this
Lucid for this long hurts the dreaming
fills in all the gaps things have always
been even as they are brought into being
I've been on this Cliff since the
beginning of time just like how this
place has always been here the dream was
torn Away by the deaths of gods Before
Time began but I watched it happen 5
years ago are you
following I can barely tell the dream
and reality apart anymore my world has
always been the way it is and we made it
like that we hurt the dreaming the shark
that's how we see it we heard it killed
it in our world and the dream time
poured out like it spilled blood and we
made this big scar here and and things
are wrong fish walk and ghosts haunt the
stones and women give birth to plastic
children and the leech Fields stretch
out forever in the Seas of human blood
and the center eats cocaine and caviar
out of pandas skull bows on the crushed
backs of op mares in acres of broken
glass and it has always been like this
don't don't do it don't do it again
you're already racing back down to the
dead jaged Hills the side of the
deranged Nikolai burned into your mind a
man reduced to a babbling lunatic Cast
Away and left alone in this strange
dream skate that SCP 1449 brought you to
but Nikolai is more than that more than
just someone driven mad by his isolation
he is a grim prophecy of what will
become of you unless you can find a way
to leave the Dreamtime whale sharks
World already back on the beach you drop
down kneeling in the wet sand as the
tide washes over your knees the how or
why of SCP 1449 bringing you into this
dream isn't important all that matters
to you is avoiding ending up like
Nikolai whatever it takes you know one
thing above all else you need to wake up
but whether you actually ever will is
enough question entirely 40 years ago a
US Navy exploratory vessel landed on a
chain of islands in the South Atlantic
just 2,000 Mi off the coast of Argentina
in other words the middle of nowhere yet
on this far off set of rocks afloat in
the middle of the ocean they discovered
a vast array of strange wildlife and
plant species that resemble little of
what they left behind on the mainland
could this be a treasure Trove of
undiscovered species they wondered
hoping to capitalize on the Discovery a
reconnaissance team of researchers was
sent out to explore some of the islands
on foot and what they found did not
disappoint from endangered species of
birds to plant life and vegetation that
looked like it belonged on Mars they
found a dizzying array of new and
exciting examples of evolutionary
Oddities that would fill a library but
unfortunately their Jubilation was cut
short attempting to collect soil samples
they dug into the ground and soon
discovered that what they were standing
on wasn't actually ground at all the
Navy scientists soon discovered the
rocky terrain they were exploring was
actually made up entirely of organic
matter as per the standard protocol the
SCP Foundation was forced to silence the
US Navy research vessel after its
Discovery with the okay from the US
government the ship was torpedoed and
sunk to the bottom of the ocean with all
hands on deck in the name of protecting
the greater good of the masses a tragedy
at sea for the sake of preventing
worldwide pandemonia from there the
foundation took over with the
containment procedures of what would
eventually come to be known as SCP 169
better known by its nickname the
Leviathan The Leviathan is a Biblical
creature of mythical proportions said to
be able to boil the Seas and create
Earth ending floods with just a whip of
its massive continent spanning body it
is unclear if SCP 169 has the ability to
do these things though given its massive
size which Foundation researchers
estimate to be somewhere between 2,000
and 8,000 kilm it's easy to see how
something that big moving at any speed
could be devastating for the coastal
regions of the world although we use the
word contain it is impossible for SCP
staff to ever contain something of such
massive size surveillance and monitoring
are about all we can do for now that in
hope it never wakes up and decides that
we are on the menu it was thought to be
relatively smooth sailing until one
incident changed everything Dr Hart
turned off the video monitor and faced
the assembled members of MTF gamma 6
also known as the Deep feeders renowned
for their specialization in the tracking
of deep sea and oceanic anomalies the
room was dark and each team member was
sitting in Shadow but still Dr Hart
could see the seriousness on their faces
I'm sure you're wondering why I called
you here at such short notice he said on
the screen behind him he put up a NASA
satellite picture of a small set of
Rocky Islands you see this little island
chain here well it wasn't there a week
ago he paused rubbing his forehead from
lack of sleep at 8:05 a.m. today we
recorded another auditory anomaly
emitting from SCP 169 this one was much
louder and longer than the one recorded
in 1997 by the National Oceanic and
Atmospheric Administration the one known
as the bloop back back then it was easy
to brush off as some ice breaking off of
a continental shelf and scraping against
the seaf Flor it's not so easy to cover
up anymore these auditory emissions from
SCP 169 are beginning to grow more
frequent more than that increased
seismic activity around the archipelago
on the creature's back indicates that
the rate at which the creature is
breathing is also up typically the rate
at which the creature takes what we are
assuming to be a breath is once every 3
months the rate has increased to once
every 3 weeks for as long as we've been
monitoring SCP 169 it's been a drift
along the southern Atlantic never moving
more than a kilometer a week that
behavior is slowly beginning to change
it doesn't sound like much but something
that big even moving just a fraction of
that faster means 100 ft tidal waves for
the entire South American Coastline We
Fear the creatures showing signs of
waking up if this is true it could mean
a cataclysm for the hundreds of Nations
around the world Millions hell even
billions could be wiped off the face of
the Earth if this thing just flips its
body to fast in the wrong direction to
put it to scale this monster is about
the size of the Caribbean maybe even
bigger as far as we know the doctor then
pulled out a decanter of whiskey and
poured himself a glass swallowing the
entire pore in one go in an appalling
breach of workplace professionalism
seriously an XK class into of the world
scenario is still no excuse for drinking
on on the job we're talking about an
extinction level event a Bonafide XK
Class end of thee World scenario 1,000
ft tsunami weight stretching as far as
the eye can see from either end of The
Horizon the last time SCP 169 stirred it
created the medat terrain in fact the
legends of the biblical flood Noah's Arc
the same story can be found in every
civilization and culture around the
world so maybe they were on to something
it is to this end I call you all here to
save the world from the next great flood
he paused for a moment as the room took
in the gravity of the situation the more
we can learn about SCP 169 the better
right now we know squat one we've never
seen just how deep the body of the
creature goes or what's under it the
pressure has been too great for our
current model submarines until now after
reinforcing on Nemo 1 deep sea
submersible with theaterical runes the
Integrity of its ho has increased
exponentially your mission will be to
travel as far down and as close to the
creature as possible if it breathes then
there must be gills or lungs there must
be some basic biological facts we need
to understand if we're going to survive
extinction our only recourse is to find
a way to sedate the creature and if that
doesn't work then God help us all just
12 hours later deep in the waters of the
Southern Atlantic a massive submersible
ship was diving down into the depths of
the deep potion looking for a way to
stop the end of the world agent ja 6-1 a
member of deep feeders looked out of the
massive viewing Port as the ship slowly
descended alongside the rocky trench
that made up the body of SCP 169 behind
him was Dr Hart sporting a white 5:00
shadow and a red nose from a night of
drinking to calm his nerves the entire
crew were silent in awe as the giant
flood lights of the ship brushed over
the Barnacle covered surfaces of the
unders Mountain they progressed slowly
reaching each milestone in depth with
caution knowing that one wrong move
could destabilize the pressure in their
ship J 6-1 murmured the word scales what
asked Dr Hart I've been watching the
patterns of The Ridges as we sink down
they look like scales giant segments
it's hard to see at first because
they're so covered in Barnacles and
sediment but I'm sure of it they're
giant armored scales the way lobsters or
crabs have armored exoskeletons
interesting the doctor said scratching
his chin arthopods have segmented
armored bodies this means we might be
looking at some sort of evolutionary
hybrid some sort of aquatic mammal such
as a whale or dolphin one that has
developed armored segmented scales
similar to that of a crustation the
doctor crossed his arms to think the
closest thing we have on the fossil
record of this magnitude is an armored
fish from the Cretaceous Period but even
that's way too small to compare to this
this thing has an entire e system on its
back how old is it asked the agent well
now that you mention it given the
impossible age of the creature an
arthropod would make sense lobsters and
other crustations don't age
conventionally you see they are
effectively Immortal in fact they
actually die because they continue to
grow until their bodies can't hold up
their humongous size anymore yet SCP 169
just kept growing the doctor trailed off
thinking to himself Dr Hart still lost
in thought turned to walk to the back of
the submersible as ja 6-1 followed he
said as much to himself as to the agent
the creature is old the Geological
Survey conducted when SCP 169 was first
discovered carbon dated the specimen to
over 541 million years old as you can
probably surmise that's too old for any
living being the results had to be
incorrect and yet I checked them myself
more than once and numbers do not lie
The Entity predates our civilization
hell it predates complex life forms on
this planet as we know it from an
evolutionary standpoint it doesn't make
any sense the agent confused asked
doctor how could something so big even
come into existence very little of our
planet is actually land mass it's a
wonder we call it Earth most of this
planet is water we aren't looking at a
creature that's on our planet agent we
are on each planet just then a flurry of
alarms and sensors began to go off at
the bridge of the ship the team
scrambled through their stations
checking off monitors and shouting
readings to each other the ship's
thermal sensors are detecting a massive
rise in temperature transmitting power
to cooling systems we have activity
Northwest of our location sonar has
something bigheaded in our way we need
to dive now the ship lged forward nose
first as everyone on board held on to
their seats the restraints keeping them
from falling forward just outside of the
viewing Port Dr Hart could see an
enormous scaled appendage moving fast in
their location we need to steer the ship
clear of the talons revert all power to
the thrusters get us out of the way the
doctor yelled don't you think I'm doing
that the captain shouted back the ship
jolted sideways and downwards as an
immense wave of pressure came over the
submersible putting six G's of force on
its occupants ja 6-1 yelped out of fear
as the ship came close to crashing into
what appeared to be the edge of a
Titanic Talon the size of the Empire
State Building following the encounter
the part of the ship bordering the
reinforced glass glass of the viewing
Port began to Glow bright red it's
boiling the water around us one of the
crew members cried out it's not boiling
anything it's just cavitation due to the
pressure reduction in the water the
updated ruins on the ship's Hall should
keep us safe we just need to cool our
heads stay focused on the mission Bottom
Feeders after several moments of holding
their breaths the crew of Nemo 1 began
to relax as their Pace returned to a
slow descent along the side of the
underwater Behemoth before long The
Vessel was no longer traveling straight
down but starting to curve under the
creature traveling north towards the
theoretical head of SCP 169 after
several hours the ship Came Upon giant
fissures in the Rocky exterior of the
creature these massive vent likee
structures appeared stiff but slowly
they opened and closed over the span of
weeks these were the respiratory organs
of the organism clocking in at over 2
miles underneath the surface of the
ocean the crew carefully began entering
the smaller pod-like submersibles that
detach from the main ship ja 6-1 entered
his pod and strapped on the haptic
gloves that would give him control of
the pod's robotic arms he and a team of
three other volunteers had agreed to
undergo The Dangerous Mission of
attaching artificial chemical emission
machines that could be programmed to
release anesthetic gas into SCP 169
respiratory system on command remotely
the emission machines could be refueled
manually whenever the contents ran out
it was an ingenious solution Dr Hart
came up with when thinking of his time
studying sharks as a marine biologist it
would tag the fins of sharks by
capturing them and bringing the
specimens on the deck of their boat from
there the scientist would drill a radio
frequency emitter onto the fin of the
shark when he had first seen this
practice as a young college student Dr
Hart was afraid the process was harming
the shark but later he learned it was
designed in a way to not be harmful to
the specimen and eventually the tag
would fall off after enough data on the
shark's movement was collected except
these tags would not be falling off he
thought they could not for the sake of
all mankind this had to work the doctor
pressed a button on the receiver of the
radio and spoke just 6-1 what's your
status pressure's holding all signs look
good 6-2 precious holding all good Z 6-3
all clear Captain 6-4 there was silence
just 6-4 do you copy all clear doc sorry
my M was muted on Route and ready to do
this thing Dr Hart sighed in relief and
slowly reclined in his chair watching
the pods move closer to the large
openings on SCP 169 side one by one the
robotic arms used underwater torches to
drill into the thick rock-like
exoskeleton of the creature screwing in
complex million dooll equipment that was
both waterproof and could withstand the
immense pressure at such a depth under
the ocean as the minutes turned to hours
Dr Hart couldn't help but feel anxiety
for the safety of his crew and the
success of the mission but before long
the pods began to return one by one to
the mothercraft each completing the
segment of work with which they were
tasked the last pod still working was J
6-1 whose robotic arm was in the process
of rotating a large industrial size
screw ja 6-1 had all but finished when
suddenly a low Rumble could be felt
shaking the larger submersible Dr Hart's
voice came crackling over the radio get
back to the ship now just 6-1 wrapped in
deep focus on his task replied I'm just
about finished just packing up my tool
belt leave it return to the ship now
that's an order Jesus what's wrong it's
not like this is the end of the world
said the agent chuckling over his radio
an earpiercing echo sent shock waves
through the depths of the ocean around
the submersible the waves rumbled with
the sound of SCP 169 voice similar to
the sound of a large whale but Amplified
by a million the sound sent all the crew
members falling to the floor as the ship
experienced severe damage from the burst
of pressure slightly cracking the glass
viewport and sending smoke flooding into
the small Bridge of the ship gas masks
shouted Dr Hart as they all Dawn
breathing apparatus SCP 169 is waking up
begin activation of the chemical
emission machines we need to sedate it
now the Leviathan is waking up we need
to stop it shouted Dr Hart just then he
looked back and noticed J 6 d1's Pod was
gone J 6-1 what's your position J 6- one
where are you s Sona has him drifting
off deeper into the ocean behind us he
must have gotten knocked off as SCP 169
by the Shark Wave but Dr Hart wouldn't
have it he didn't want any more blood on
his hands reverse thrusters turn us
around and get to him we're not losing
anyone but the breach in the hull it a
hole that's what the ruins are for the
outside of the submersible began to Glow
a slight blue as the ship system started
to come back online to full capacity and
alarm system started to turn off and
Report normal pressure readings before
before long the Nemo 1 had caught up to
ja 61's pod and retrieved the agent but
been knocked unconscious by the shock
wave once the agent was back on the main
ship the doctor turned his attention
back to the monitors making sure the
installations they drilled into the
creature were functional slowly the
machines came online to full power and
the speed at which SCP 169 had been
moving began to slow ever so slightly
the team all watched the viewport in
silence as a steady stream of anesthetic
gas was pumped into into the respiratory
system of the gigantic living myth in
front of them after a few moments of
waiting the doctor spoke I think it
worked he said with a smile the crew
erupted in cheers as they radioed
control back up on land that the mission
had been a success the message quickly
reached the 05 Council where a red alert
status was de-escalated and the 05
members withdrew from their plan of
leaving the current Earth for that of an
alternate universe the whole crew began
to sing and celebrate the prevention of
the end of the world as Dr Hart simply
stood in front of the massive viewport
watching the mountainous specimen slowly
grow smaller in the distance as the
submersible began ascending back to the
world above ja 6-1 came over to
congratulate him patting him on the back
we did it he said loosen up the doctor
managed to laugh along in
acknowledgement that we did he said in
relief that we did the two watched the
deep blue ocean in silence taking in the
vastness of the sea perhaps this would
not be the end of it but that day they
had done what the SCP Foundation did
best kick that apocalyptic can a few
miles down the road and sometimes in the
face of the terrifying and the infinite
that's really the best you can do it was
a beautiful day in Sardinia the second
largest Italian island in the
Mediterranean the sea was clear the air
was hot and the beaches were golden but
the kagari diving Club couldn't see any
of that they were roughly 250 M
underneath the Mediterranean Sea given
the rich and extensive history of the
area they were sure to find some
interesting historical artifacts on the
ocean floor and they were indeed about
to find something incredible but this
history wasn't quite as dead as some old
Roman Pottery Paulo bonacell the most
experienced diver was the deepest of all
they decided to be a little more
ambitious this time than in previous
Dives 20 mi off the Sardinian Coast for
Paulo it was Uncharted Territory so you
could only imagine how amazed and
delighted he was when he saw the shape
of what seemed like a small town beneath
the water Old Stone buildings and a
classic Roman or Grecian Style with
roofs made of thatched seaweed he
gestured to his fellow divers to follow
him they were amazed at how well
preserved the buildings seemed to be as
though they were still being lived in
and actively maintained to this day
despite being around 300 M underwater if
they were able to take some pictures and
collect some artifacts they'd be the
talk of the local historic community and
probably be able to finagle a payout
from the whole experience too that's
when Paulo spotted something truly
amazing a larger more impressive
structure like a miniature Palace
surrounded by grandio statues of
humanoid figures in a circle around the
little Palace each of the statues was an
imposing 5 m tall with a faint Golden
Light emanating from each of them while
the statues were humanoid they
definitely weren't human their features
were strange and fish-like scales gills
tentacles Paulo was in awe at the sight
of them he took pictures and got closer
there was also a huge chasm in front of
the building perhaps some kind of
underwater thermal vent Paulo was
curious he wanted to investigate further
he swam deeper and deeper what was at
the bottom of that Chasm but lucky for
Paulo he would never see what was at the
bottom of that Chasm before he could
reach it something intercepted him from
the side something large and fast he
felt a white hot flash of pain as claw
raked across his chest tearing open the
rubber of his wet suit Paulo turned eyes
widening in horror to see a creature
staring at him like the statues it was
humanoid but not human
an anthropomorphic sea monster with
greenish skin its arms and legs coated
in thin scales its neck serrated into
fleshy gills he could see scraps of his
suits rubber hanging from its claws it
bore a mouthful of fangs and gave a
silent but threatening snarl Pao could
see something in the distance behind
this creature more figures like this one
emerging from The Merc getting faster
getting closer Pao was a smart man but
it didn't take a genius to realize that
if he stuck around something terrible
was about to happen to him and the rest
of the kagari diving Club he turned and
fled paddling with all his might away
from the coming Legion of aquatic beasts
the rest of the club saw the experienced
diver panicking and followed his lead
thanks to their quick thinking and
expertise they all managed to escape
with their lives and only a few minor
injuries but they had no idea of the
true extent of the mystery they were
leaving behind Beneath the Sea the
Multiverse is a big place there are
alternate universes where the devour of
Worlds escapes and destroys everything
we love and hold dear there are
alternate universes where the SCP
Foundation has gone haywire and
attempted to wipe out Humanity through
controlled releases of all their
anomalies there are even universes where
a kill Squad sent by the chaos
Insurgency hunts down and assassinates
every member of the 05 Council before
replacing them and leading the
foundation into a bold New Era and there
are some universes where the SCP
Foundation is Italian we've covered SCP
057 on this channel before in our video
on the most frightening rooms in the SCP
universe but you've never seen this SCP
057 because this is the Italian version
SCP
057 this localized anomaly off the coast
of Sardinia is under the purview of the
Italian division of the SCP Foundation
which works autonomously with its own
systems and terminology this SCP is in a
frightening room that crushes its
trapped victims together this anomaly is
an entire city 300 M beneath the water
of the Mediterranean Sea everyone has
heard of the mythical lost city of
Atlantis a supposed underwater Utopia
outlined by such great historical Minds
as the ancient Greek philosopher Plato
it's something that people fantasize
about a beautiful idyllic Society under
the sea divorc from all the petty
squabbles we deal with up on land but is
everything really better down where it's
wetter let's take a look and see when
Paulo and the rest of the kagari diving
Club returned to the surface they were
happy to tell anyone that would listen
that they encountered aggressive merman
and an entire underwater city off the
coast of Sardinia they even posted their
photos onto their official Facebook page
along with photos of Paulo's gnarly
chest scars that's when the Italian
branch of the SCP Foundation finally
discovered them and decided to intervene
the foundation dispatched an sir Squad
known as Oria Nota sirs are the
intelligence and research section of the
Italian SCP Foundation a kind of mobile
task force that investigates possible
informational leads Paulo and his team
were given amnestic treatment and any
evidence that they' collected was
scrubbed from existence meanwhile
Lieutenant Marco levini leader of the
mobile task force ssm2 Squad AKA leio
Alanis was being dispatched to the
source of the problem SCP 057 it itself
what started off as a relatively
straightforward exploratory Mission soon
took an extremely strange turn lini and
his men reported activity down in the
underwater city observing from the
safety of their armored Foundation
submarine while the Aquatic humanoids
living in 057 it were UND ibly the same
species their cultur seemed to be split
up into two unique groups one group had
thinner scales on their arms and legs
this group was more numerous having at
least 60 active specimens and was
characterized by their extreme
aggression towards any Outsiders as for
the smaller group they had thicker
scales as well as a number of eily
consistent injuries to their hands feet
and gills they were also distinct from
the thin scales in terms of behavior as
they were a far friendlier more Curious
bunch at times members of this subset
would approach the submarine and regard
it with detached Fascination sometimes
they would even point at the submarine
and laugh though their reasons for doing
this are unknown eventually Lieutenant
lavini was so confident in their safety
around the myr people that he and a few
other team members decided to disembark
from the submarine on a diving Excursion
and properly explore the Aquatic City
below this would prove to be a dangerous
tactical error on lini's part part
during what seemed like a routine
exploratory mission levini was ambushed
by a squadron of thin scales grabbed
from behind and kidnapped he was taken
as a hostage and Spirited Away into one
of the city's various buildings where a
thick scale known as Leia acted as his
Warden but lini soon found that being
under letizia's care was a profoundly
lucky turn of events on his part both
because it allowed him to learn more
about the situation and because she was
one of the small group left in the city
who who hadn't become dangerous Fanatics
that's right the myrr people were in the
middle of a heated Civil War both from
the observations of levini during his
captivity and later interviews conducted
by project head Dr jeppi pastillo with
some liberated members of the thick
scales they learned that a terrible
religious conflict had broken out in SCP
057 the accounts coming from the rescued
citizens Illustrated a similar backstory
to what the Italian Foundation had
theorized guarding the myr people they
were the descendants of people that
lived on the island of nisos up to the
14th century BCE before it was
devastated by a volcanic eruption
forcing them into the ocean where they
evolved the ability to live in aquatic
environments through anomalous means
since this change this new species had
been operating in Mediterranean Waters
migrating regularly in order to avoid
detection passing their way of life from
generation to generation as the world
changed and shifted above them in many
ways they were quite similar to humans
such as their reproductive habits they
mate and reproduce after a gestation
period more like animals than fish
though their gestation period is
slightly shorter than human beings at 6
months they largely speak Latin though
the oldest myr person among them also
speaks ancient Greek myr children born
in Foundation containment have shown
strong language acquisition skills as
they have proven more than able to learn
modern Italian and even more fascinating
from a standpoint of sociological study
the myrr people have formed their own
unique culture under the sea and this is
where the problems started abstaining
from the belief of the Greek and Roman
pantheons their ancestors looked up to
the myr people instead worshiped their
own group of water-bound deities whose
images were reflected in the great
statues in the center of the town the
large building near the statues and the
chasm was the home of the m May the
town's de facto leader however what had
been a workable system for centuries
began falling to ruin when a strange
religious fanaticism began to spread a
cult-like group soon formed and began
holding ceremonies where they worshiped
a powerful entity in the chasm known as
the great eye this new cult was known as
The Cult of the great eye of the
Mediterranean or cjem for short what
began as a fringe belief soon became a
frenzy and took over the better part of
the town with the acolytes of the great
eye proving themselves more than willing
to spread the gospel of their new deity
with violence some of the more arduin
non-believers were killed for their
heresy While others were simply
ritualistically mutilated in order to
prevent them from rebelling letisia had
her own evidence of these targeted
mutilations the thin scales had cut the
Aquatic webbing from between her fingers
and toes making it harder for her to
swim away and Escape other suspected
Heretics were given the same same
treatment the reason the thick scales
even had thicker scales was that they
stole forbidden technology from the
mayor to increase the strength of their
scales hoping it would help them better
withstand the torments of the acolytes
those involved in the stealing of this
technology were captured and summarily
executed for their acts of defiance in a
sense Letizia was protecting levini by
advising him against trying to escape
knowing the acolytes of the great eye
would kill him if he did she knew that
the only opportunity for escape would
come during the ceremony held by the
acolytes to honor their frightening
Master when the day eventually came as
lavini was running low on everything
from food to oxygen everyone in the town
was forced out into the Town Center to
witness the ritual the acolytes gathered
around the chasm and began to chant in a
frightening unknown language as they
chanted a blinding light began to
emanate from the chasm and as blurry
shapes emerged nightmarish tentacled G
astropod soon began to take form truly
lovecraftian under sea monsters shortly
after the ritual the Vinnie and the
thick scales were able to make a break
for it pursued by the acolytes of the
great eye it was a close one but
thankfully due to the intervention and
assistance of a trained mobile task
force the fanatical forces of the
acolytes were repelled and the fleeing
myr people along with leini were rescued
a number of thick scales are now
willingly confined at site netuno an
Italian found Foundation containment
site where they have undergone numerous
interviews with Foundation staff
incidentally among them is the oldest
Myerson previously present in SCP
057 the only one who spoke ancient Greek
fluently he was different from the
others extremely different in fact he
was a deity made into flesh one of the
deities replaced by the worshippers of
the great eye this unfortunate former
God had done everything to keep his
people's lives safe and peaceful but in
spite of his wisdom and best efforts
hell had once again broken loose not
everything is all well and good in SCP
057 it even if a human's body changes
their nature does not and the worst
parts of human nature seemingly followed
these unfortunate myr people into what
should have been their Paradise under
the sea but all hope isn't lost if you
were to judge the entire human race on
one community in turmoil you probably
wouldn't leave with a very favorable
impression of us either correspondence
with a French branch of the SCP
Foundation reveals that my creatures
aren't just localized to one Waring
underwater city in Sardinia mermaids
have also been discovered and confirmed
by Foundation field agents off the coast
of France 80% of the oceans Still
Remains unmapped to this day who knows
what else is out there just waiting to
be found Dr reard had lost everything
his job the respect of his peers and if
everyone else was right perhaps even his
mind it was 11:00 p.m. when he staggered
to the edge of Okanagan Lake in British
Columbia eyes and judgment clouded with
booze this Lake could have been what
made his career as a researcher for the
SCP Foundation but now that bright
future was slipping through his fingers
like the dry silt beneath his feet he
looked hatefully across the endless dark
surface of the water and loudly cursed
stupid empty place just hours ago he'd
been stripped of his ranks and released
from his position at the foundation for
wasting the organization's time and
resources on frivolous personal projects
frivolous he thought what a terrible
joke just because the higher-ups refused
to acknowledge what was going out here
didn't mean it wasn't there Moonlight
shimmered off the water surface wait was
that Moonlight or was there something
lurking underneath the water to tr truly
answer this question if any answer is
possible at all we need to go back to
the beginning and ask ourselves a
different question how does the SCP
Foundation actually find most of the
anomalies it cataloges and contains it
is a simple question with a multifaceted
answer depending on the anomaly in
question for the most part the
foundation has a network of field agents
embedded in pretty much every
institution across the globe including
rival groups of Interest like the global
occult coalition and the Serpent's hand
if they so much as sniff the strange and
unusual they alert the nearest site
director and the necessary Personnel are
dispatched to the scene there's also the
foundation web crawlers which are a form
of specialized software constantly
patrolling the web for anomalous
activity that the foundation wants to
know about and one of the rare but still
incredibly important methods of finding
scps involve looking into myths and
local Legends sure it may seem like a
good way to waste time and resources
but the crossover between recorded scps
and folklore is surprisingly common take
SCP 1000 the formerly hyper intelligent
Apes that were nearly the dominant
species on Earth until humans and a
certain capricious Forest God pulled the
dirty trick on them they're better known
to most civilians as the legendary
Bigfoot or Sasquatch perhaps the most
famous crypted of all time or as CP 1337
The Hitchhiker an anomalous spectral
entity that manifests in the cars of
those who don't pick her up and performs
horrific acts of violence against them
she's eerily similar to Legends you can
find not only all over the us but the
entire world of ghostly hitchhikers
intruding into the cars of unwary
Travelers and scaring them half to death
or worse if you're unlucky another case
where myths and legends pointed the SCP
Foundation in exactly the right
direction and of course there's SCP 136
the terrifying naked dog
this was an almost featureless
children's doll found inside an
abandoned house but prolonged time in
its presence can make you the victim of
a warped Apparition that'll drive you
half mad with fear it's got such a
detrimental psychological effect on
people that the foundation has been
controversially using it as a torture
method during enhanced interrogation
sessions with captured members of rival
groups of interest and how did they find
it the foundation keeps track of
neighborhood rumors about haunted houses
with supposedly Supernatural in
inhabitants clearly when it looks like
it might actually get results no myth or
local Legend is too big or too small to
Warrant an investigation from the SCP
Foundation it was with this mindset that
a younger happier and less drunk Dr B
Renard set off with his team to Okanagan
Lake in search of what locals had
referred to as the legendary Ogo Pogo
we've all heard of the Loch Ness monster
the lake monster from Scotland that's
been turning heads for the better part
of a century and may be related to two
other similar scps namely SCP 3934 and
SCP 5533 but Ogo Pogo is canid as answer
to good old Nessie while the Loch Ness
monster resembles a plaur the Ogopogo is
much more Serpentine with a long coiling
body covered in green scales its long
tail is said to be able to create Fierce
storms along the surface of the water
with its vicious whips killing scores of
unfortunate adventurers who dared stray
too close the name ooo go is also a
palindrome meaning it reads the same
forwards as it does backwards and is
believed to have originated in the
novelty song from the year
1924 however it's likely that the actual
Beast this somewhat Goofy name was given
to is a much older fiercer entity and
for the sake of his reputation as a
researcher as he took a plane to the
Okanagan Valley Dr rard very much hoped
this was the case of course he'd
explored the Legends heavily so much so
that he was sure that there had to be
something to this whole thing the
schmeck and celix peoples the lake
dwelling monster was known as nit taka
which has been Loosely translated into
the sacred creature of the water the
water God and most menacing of all the
water demon the Beast was often
described in oral Traditions as being a
malicious Supernatural entity with great
power and ill intent towards those
trespassing on its territory Legend has
it that anyone who crosses Okanagan Lake
the supposed domain of the o hogo needs
to make a sacrifice to the monster in
order to ensure safe passage those who
refuse to give this sacrifice the Beast
demanded would pay a heavy toll being
devoured or dragged down to a watery
grave never to be seen again and this
monster isn't just some old folk tale
either contemporary sightings have dated
back to 1873 with both settlers and
First Nations people alike spotting the
Sinister Ogopogo in the intervening
years Dr reard had poured through the
files on hundreds of of sightings there
were a number of incidents in the 1980s
so much so that the environmentalist
Group Green Piece moved to have the
creature classified as a protected
species naturally official sources
decided against the idea claiming that
none of the sightings were of substance
in 1992 a vast shape filmed under the
murky water in Okanagan Lake was
suggested to be the legendary beast
however the FBI stepped in to deny the
validity of this case stating that the
Beast was much more likely to be debris
falling off a local tree disappointing
lovers of the strange and unusual
everywhere in 2011 nearly 20 years later
there was more video footage of a
sighting showing large dark shapes
moving underneath the surface of the
Okanagan Lake however this claim was
once again dismissed by all outside
parties claiming the shape of the Beast
underneath the water was more likely to
be a pair of logs bummer 2018 was an
exciting year for the yoogo with three
different sightings of the creature
being reported at different times
throughout the year Witnesses describe
the creature as being a giant snake
around 50 ft long which is consistent
with a lot of the historical
descriptions of the Beast as well as
being over twice as long as the
reticulated python the non-anomalous
longest snake in the world so naturally
authority figures once again shot down
the validity of any claims that the
creature was actually real and out there
Dr reard found this almost funny they
didn't even need to suppress knowledge
of this creature if it really was there
mainstream sources seemed to be doing
their job for them and keeping the
creature covered up he was determined
though that he would be the one to prove
to his superiors that this creature was
indeed real and lurking in Okanagan Lake
he organized a number of varied
investigative missions from actively
trolling the lake itself to conducting
interviews with firsthand witnesses as
well as those who claim to see no merit
in their evidence and testimony Dr reard
noticed a strange phenomenon the people
who'd seen it firsthand were as certain
that it was real as the doubters were
that it was fake even for typical
Skeptics the non-believers seem
shockingly Resolute that there was
really nothing down there and the
alleged photos and videos were 100%
bogus early diagnostic tests into the
lake directly overseen by Dr Renard
seemed to point to a creature clearly
being down there he found the direct
testimony both compelling and consistent
with what he and his team were catching
glimpses of so why were people so
adamant that that nothing was down there
it was almost like the yoogo really was
as mythical as the First Nations Legends
said and it was casting a spell on all
the non-believers that's when it hit Dr
Renard like a perfect bolt of lightning
they weren't just looking at a
particularly large sea snake with
unnatural longevity here they were
looking at a sea serpent with Cognito
hazardous Powers it was a beast with a
perfect defense mechanism only those who
s up close would actually believe that
the creature was real anyone one who
found out about it via secondary sources
would experience an extreme state of
incredulity nobody except those who saw
it directly would ever believe that it
existed and thus even the most
intelligent prey would lower their
defenses around its domain an elegant
and dangerous anomalous Hunter Dr rard
had found himself a worthy opponent and
one that would help him make his Mark at
the foundation he drew up the file and
gave it the designation SCP 1933 before
sending it back to his supervisors they
wrote back saying that they didn't feel
as though there was enough of a basis in
evidence to deem this entry worthy of
inclusion if Dr Renard wanted to have
his so-called Ogopogo dignified with
entry into the SCP Foundation archives
he needed to back it up properly this
presented a problem to Dr Renard how
could he provide documentation and
evidence for a creature that had the
defining anomalous power of making all
of its own documentation and evidence
seemed phony he was caught between a
rock and a hard place with only one
solution create the most undeniably
highquality evidence of the creature
that the world had ever seen not long
after that his superiors at the SCP
Foundation would receive a video file
from Dr Renard according to the notes on
his report he set up a track using an
ALK carcass to lure the creature out of
the water and capture HD video of its
feeding when the senior researchers
gathered around to watch the video they
were astounded an animatronic a cheap
rubber suit around a somewhat janky
robot like something you'd see at a
theme park how much had Dr rard spent on
this absurd farce did he think it was
funny despite Dr Renard's protests he
was reprimanded severely for this waste
of foundation resources the object class
on his 1933 file was switched to
explained meaning a rational
non-anomalous explanation for The
observed phenomenon had been found
discrediting it and the 1933 slot was
instead filled with a strange fat man
dressed as Santa Claus whose Bott fluids
are all Irish Cream the ultimate
humiliation Dr Renard was left with
nothing and we join him once again where
we started with Dr reard standing on the
ledge of Okanagan Lake staring hatefully
into the water as something seemed to
move underneath if Dr rard screamed that
night there was nobody there to hear it
his remains were dredged out of the lake
the next day His official cause of death
was listed as drowning after an
unfortunate boating accident though the
boat in question was never found reports
that his corpse was found half eaten
have mostly been dismissed as rumors
after all there is no such thing as the
Ogo Pogo the diver screams A Silent
Scream as the giant Squid's beak digs
into his skin it's many grasping
tentacles grabbing him and holding him
in place nearby his fellow divers are
driven half mad with Terror as they see
mysterious figures floating towards them
through the The Merc and strange Russian
voices speaking in their heads nobody
can help them they're down too deep too
consumed by the darkness and the
pressure of the sea they're now at the
mercy of whatever is inside the
submarine beginning in the 1940s with
the dawn of nuclear weapons the American
government conducting the world's first
atomic weapons test and the Soviet Union
responding in kind with nuclear testing
of their own the two Powers entered an
arms race fueled by rivalry and a thirst
to prove their strength on the world
stage what followed were Decades of
Staggering technological advancements as
each Nation tried to outdo and
intimidate the other the Soviet Union
crossed into the cold reaches of outer
space deploying the satellite Sputnik
the United States responded with the
founding of NASA tensions reached a
fever pitch during the Cuban Missile
Crisis of 1962 as United States citizens
feared they were teetering on the brink
of nuclear war in July of 1968 the
Soviet Union the United Kingdom and the
United States came together to sign the
treaty on the nonproliferation of
nuclear weapons agreeing to abandon
their pursuit of increasing nuclear
power and turn their focus to
disarmament but several months before
the treaty was signed the Soviet
government was dealing in Weaponry far
more dangerous than nuclear missiles
something the other world powers knew
nothing about these deadly secrets were
hidden aboard a sub Marine known as SCP
741 SCP 741 is the underwater wreckage
of a Soviet submarine that sank in March
of 1968 and came into the custody of the
SCP Foundation in 1999 the submarine a
version of the Charlie 2 class was
deployed under unusual circumstances
which attracted the attention of the
United States government in an attempt
to learn more about the submarine the US
government launched project redacted
which attempted to recover the vessel
from the ocean in the early 1970s they
managed to recover a few pieces of the
vessel though the specifics are highly
classified in the late 1990s the US
government contacted the SCP Foundation
informing them of a possible uclid or
ker class anomaly in the wreck at this
point it passed into the custody and
surveillance of the foundation the
submarine is on the ocean floor broken
into three pieces the hole was broken
into bits during project redacted
recovery attempt butd was largely intact
when it first sank except for two holes
one just in front of the sail and one
just below the starboard missile tubes
apparently the vessel sank rapidly due
to flooding after an enemy missile
strike which occurred while it was
surfacing though all parts of the
submarine are accounted for no members
of the crew have been located
additionally none of the emergency
escape equipment on board has been used
raising further questions about what
became of the crew wherever they went
they they seem to have left something
behind whenever divers are sent down to
investigate the wreckage they report
experiencing anomalous currents and
strange sea life and hearing moans
disembodied voices and incoherent
Whispering they also report seeing
blurry faintly glowing figures
Additionally the ocean life in the area
is unnaturally aggressive particularly
large squid and sharks this effect was
first noted during a Mann Expedition
into the waters around the wreckage Des
DED an incident report 1741 D divers a26
through a30 embarked from the Icebreaker
yamal into the waters below with the
intention of studying the potential
anomalous activity surrounding the
wreckage as the group of divers
approached the submarine they could feel
the shift in the water around them the
oppressive feeling of abnormally
increasing pressure bearing down and
threatening to crush them if their
specialized diving equipment were to
fail they knew that that would be it and
the command would would have to come and
fish their corpses out of the water or
even worse they would vanish entirely
meeting the same mysterious fate as the
crew of that doomed submarine but they
couldn't fix it on that they had a job
to do at first glance the wreckage
appeared undisturbed unchanged since the
previous inspection still they needed to
take a closer look to be sure as the
team got closer to the vessel a30 was
startled by the sight of movement from
within the wreckage spotting motion
through one of the holes in the
structure as something passed by he
pointed it out to his colleagues but
they dismissed it as likely a giant
isopod or spider crab which were
crawling all over the surrounding area
a30 laughed off his jumpiness agreed
that they were probably right and
continued the exploration as planned
control authorized the divers to proceed
to the next step and a29 activated sonar
and lights moving toward the starboard
side breach there a faint glowing caught
his eye the glow resembled that of
radioactive material but when the team
checked the radiation levels in the area
they remained stable whatever the source
of the glow was it wasn't radioactive at
this point his Neutron counter began to
register something and all of a sudden a
disembodied voice could be heard saying
vili yini can you hear me the voice was
muffled and though it could be heard
over their communication channels it
emanated from somewhere in the wreckage
deep deep underwater as a29 watched a
glowing shape emerged from the darkness
it was only an outline the suggestion of
a silhouette but the shape was
undeniably familiar it looked like a
person the other divers quickly noted
the apparation too and began to panic
some checked their nitrogen levels
believing it to be some sort of nitrogen
Narcosis While others pointed out that
they couldn't all be suffering from
nitrogen Narcosis at the same time the
unknown voice continued speaking saying
help me this get getting hard to breathe
the divers debated what to do next
questioning whether what they were
seeing was even real when all at once
the humanoid figure vanished from sight
the divers attempted to shake off the
startling encounter and they resumed
their duties the investigation
proceeding as normal after a few moments
of uneventful work another Interruption
presented itself in the form of a 5 m
long squid swimming around the wreckage
its presence startled the divers at
first particularly those closest to the
animal but the others encouraged them to
ignore it citing the fact that there are
no records of these squid attacking
humans so they did continuing their work
as the squids circled them with apparent
curiosity a27 spotted an unusual shell
below the wreckage notably large and
difficult to identify and control
requested that they bring it up to the
surface for further inspection by a
marine biologist the diver began
attaching Hall cables to the Shell as
the squid crept closer and closer all of
a sudden a 26 screamed and there was a
sudden Bloom of blood in the water the
squid despite it being uncharacteristic
behavior for its species attacked the
diver biting him savagely prompted by
cries for help from the diving team
control began to reel a26 back towards
the surface proceeding slowly to give
him decompression time and the squid
took advantage of the slow Retreat it
chased after the diver grabbing hold of
him and biting down again tearing away
at him as it gripped him in its
tentacles still control continued
reeling him in hoping to free him from
the Squid's grasp as they yanked him to
the surface the other divers were
ordered to get themselves out of there
as fast as possible in order they gladly
obeyed as they swam back to the surface
a30 saw something else moving in the
depths he couldn't make out what it was
but the sight of it gave him a sick
feeling of dread deep in the pit of his
stomach the four divers were recovered
alive along with the shell examination
of the shell indicated that it resembled
that of the extinct orthoconic
nautiloids but it was not fossilized it
was taken for further study given the
possible implication of extinct species
anomalously manifesting in the vicinity
of SCP 714 diver a26 lost a limb and was
exposed to an unknown Venom via bites
from the attacking squid his camera was
destroyed in the process as squid are
not known to attack humans unprovoked
this Behavior has been attributed to the
influence of SCP 741 though the exact
link between the two is yet to be
determined an anomalous pressure
gradient surrounds the wreck with a
radius of approximately 250 M starting
around the center of the submarine the
pressure in this area is much greater
than it should be given the depth of the
waters there this unusually high
pressure makes sonar analysis extremely
difficult as well as threatening the
safety of any divers in the vicinity of
the rack the few records that the
foundation has managed to obtain from
the Russian and US governments indicate
that the submarine was being used to
transport some sort of secret cargo
though the specifics of this cargo are
still unknown there is reason to believe
that it differed from any type of
nuclear or chemical Weaponry on a date
redacted from official files the scps
basti was patrolling the area around SCP
741 when it sonar detected some unknown
entity approaching SCP 741 from the
south at a pace of 46 knots the crew
compared the acoustic signature of the
contact with known submarines and
Torpedoes but could not find a match the
bisti attempted to reach the contact via
sonab buoi drops and active sonar pings
but it did not respond when the contact
crossed into the total underwater
exclusion Zone it became classified as
hostile at that point the sonar recorded
sounds of an undersee missile launch and
basti responded with the utmost urgency
the ship broke away from its original
area and fired a type 53 torpedo at the
underwater threat 15 seconds after the
bisti launched it its torpedo missiles
of an unidentified configuration were
seen breaking the water flying at a
height of 1.8 m and a velocity of .92
mock the missiles did not emit any
detectable radar nor did they respond to
any launch chaff or flares from the
bisti both of the missiles were engaged
by bis's 3K N5 kinsol surfac to aair
missiles and ctan point defense systems
and were destroyed at 18800 M and 210 M
from Impact respectively after the
missiles were neutralized the Hostile
vessel could be heard engaging in
evasive maneuvers at this point there
were four closely spaced explosions and
the sound of a submarine disintegrating
the identity of the attacker as well as
its intention toward SCP 741 have not
yet been determined the incident
resulted in the foundation research team
suggesting an expansion of the acoustic
sensor net as well as additional Patrol
and defense assets placed in the area
additionally they advised an acquisition
of undersea retaliatory capability the
incident was classified incident
1741 C the sonar recordings from the
scps bisti during incident 1741 DC were
taken for further analysis by the
research team the in-depth review
revealed anomalous acoustic signatures
that did not match up with any known
forms of propulsion including Magneto
hydrodynamic Drive currently the nature
of the unidentified attacker remains a
mystery and it has not been attributed
to any particular government or
organization
following the incident involving the
scps bisti an American intelligence
agent reached out to the foundation
offering further insight into the
secretive government programs looking
into SCP 741 he agreed to sit for an
interview with a foundation researcher
assigned to the project on the condition
that his identity remained protected the
SCP researcher's name is absent from the
official file as well the two men sat in
a foundation interview room and the
interviewer asked his informant why he
chose to come come forward given the US
government had simply chosen to sit on
this information for 30 years you've
seen those reports project redacted now
we know that part too how the directors
didn't make the connection is beyond me
that and the stuff the redacted pulled
up yeah the other part you don't hear
about is what some of the research team
died of and the crew Men We buried Just
Uniforms also the nuclear device we
recovered wasn't a missile or torpedo
Warhead it was a demolition charge does
that make any sense after all those
Clues I had to come forward by the
director and didn't is something I can't
fully explain this particular statement
puzzled the foundation researcher
raising questions he hadn't anticipated
only uniforms did this mean that the sub
had been unmanned the informant replied
no no not unmanned there were no bodies
but personal effects were everywhere
along with uniforms there was some blood
human before you ask on one of the
Torpedoes in a bit of skin where
somebody probably crushed his hand load
in the thing just no bodies left when I
first looked into all this I had no clue
what the hell had gone on down there but
I started putting things together the
foundation agent began to speculate
based on the mounting evidence could it
have been a Soviet weapons program a
deadly biological agent of some kind no
no it wasn't that I thought maybe it
could have been so I dialed up some of
my contacts said v preparent as spies
wind up owing each other favors after a
while and they denied it beh humanly not
your usual cover up baloney either they
clearly stated that whatever the sub was
carrying it wasn't theirs they wanted no
part of it sound like he was going to
puke when I mentioned redacted doctor do
you have any idea what it takes to make
a bioweapons researcher sick now that
wasn't what really bugged me though what
really kept me awake at night was the
KGB file that fell into our hands they
mentioned a covert op by the Soviet
military against an internal unnamed
faction to get rid of a quote terrifying
weapons that even the Soviet Union can't
safely control they wanted to lose it
whatever it was or maybe fob it off onto
the US of course that all came to light
right before the Iron Curtain fell and
given the atmosphere at the time it was
practically impossible to convince the
directors that they weren't talking
about nukes and even once I did they
still didn't even think this was worthy
of action I mean the redacted would
probably have me hang for treason if
they ever find me but it was worth the
risk and by what I can gather sounds
like Russia thinks so too Lan and you
half the Pacific Fleet and all the
interview continued after this point but
the rest of the conversation was
considered irrelevant and stricken from
the official file the interview left the
foundation with more questions than
answers though they were more certain
than ever that SCP 741 must be kept
under strict containment procedures due
to the object's location at the bottom
of the sea as well as the unusually
elevated pressure around it it is
unlikely that many civilians will come
into contact with it however as an extra
protective measure sonar and submersible
monitoring is conducted on a periodic
basis in order to verify that the
wreckage has not been interfered with in
any way the foundation contracted
Russian warships scps bisti and Kar has
been selected for this purpose if any
unauthorized activity occurs in the area
surrounding SCP 741 nuclear and
conventional missiles may be deployed
any movement of SCP 741 is grounds for
an immediate Nuclear Strike whatever
Secrets as CP 741 holds whatever it was
transporting that was even more of an
uncontrollable threat than nuclear
warfare they're better left alone down
there at the bottom of the sea Diego had
only just found his footing when it gave
out underneath him again crashing to the
ground he threw both arms over his head
just in time to protect his skull from
the rain of Boulders that came down past
him they grazed his arms and Jarred
painfully against his muscles but it was
better than having them hit him in the
head without a moment to spare Diego got
straight up to his feet and continued
running back down the trail he had been
trying to follow the ground shifted and
lurched in all directions under him
threatening to throw off his balance at
any moment having lived in Chile his
whole life he had gotten used to
earthquakes but he had never been in the
center of one like this the problem was
that the trail he had been following to
get up here was disappearing fast as the
dust swirled into the air and boulders
Landing all around him he just had to
keep running in this direction and hope
for the best there weren't any other
options but suddenly he found himself
running uphill stumbling forwards Diego
tried desperately to get his bearings he
had spent the previous 3 hours hiking up
the mountains so how was it that now
that he had turned around and gone back
he was still going uphill it was almost
as if the the ground was changing shape
beneath him as he ran dust filled his
lungs as he tried to wipe it away from
his burning eyes yes the ground was
definitely going uphill but it felt
almost as if it was lifting itself up
beneath him as if some tectonic plates
were grinding together creating a new
Mountain beneath his feet Diego lurched
unsteadily and grabbed the nearest rock
to keep his balance feeling the ground
lifting higher and higher beneath him
then all of a sudden the cloud of dust
broke and he was in fresh air Rising
ever higher into the sky the Andy
mountains stabbed out of the clouds all
around him cutting beautiful shapes
across the Horizon he felt his own
Mountain steadily growing taller than
any of them he dropped down on all
floors and clutched at the ground in
Terror as he tried his best to take in
the shape of what he was now standing
upon how far would you go to prevent a
cosmic level disaster it's one thing to
save your friends and family from an
armed murderer it's another thing to
fight for your country in a world war we
can even just about imagine what it
means to fight for our planet to save
our species from climate change to save
our world from a meteorite but what
would a cosmic disaster look like a
Calamity so Broad in scale that it
surpasses our ability to even perceive
the threat we could Point our most
advanced telescope into deep space and
look straight down the middle of it and
never know it was even there and if that
threat was not simply to the survival of
humanity or planet Earth but to the
survival of existence itself how far
would we go to prevent it what cruel and
inhumane measures would you take to have
such a threat or better yet how many
people would you kill to save the world
this debate is Raging right now as you
sit here and watch this video not among
the foundation but between two scps so
Grand in scale and so advanced in nature
that the foundation has no option but to
sit and listen as the pair debate what
to do with the human race SCP
468-1 was not difficult to discover once
it started moving in fact it was almost
impossible to ignore earthquakes have
been tearing across South America for
centuries destroying homes taking the
lives of innocent people and
fundamentally changing the shapee of our
planet itself what most people do not
realize however is that the fault line
running through the Andes mountain range
has actually largely been dormant during
this period the source of the
earthquakes has come from something far
more mysterious our innocent hiker Diego
had been spending the week walking among
the Andes when the earthquake struck you
would be forgiven for assuming as Diego
did that the ground Rising beneath his
feet was a new Mountain forming as the
tectonic plates clashed together but the
Staggering reality of the situation was
that he found himself hiking along the
back of SCP
468-1 as the creature raised its head
into the air Diego saw the head of a
serpent lifting several kilomet away
from him its body stretched and wound
its way through the mountain range
filling the valleys and running beneath
his feet the scale of SCP
468-1 is hard to convey measuring over
500 km in length this serpent is longer
than most US states with a 20 km width
standing on the back of it quite
literally feels like standing on a
mountain range for context The Horizon
at sea level is about 4.8 km away so
multiply that by four and you'll get a
sense of just how wide this thing is
even small movements from this SCP are
enough to trigger continent wide
earthquakes with tremors being felt all
the way around the world upon the
initial discovery of this SCP the
foundation was enabled to determine why
it remains dormant for such long periods
and seems to only awaken sporadically
and for brief periods of time that was
until SCP
45682 was discovered it is little wonder
that the second serpent took so long to
be found its body is comprised almost
entirely of water sand algae and steam
it does not show up on soner scans and
is incred difficult to detect in the
water even visually its form is Loosely
defined while stormant with broadly
similar measurements Top
468-1 This serpent roams the South
Pacific Ocean any Marine creatures that
swim into the scp's body find themselves
undergoing beneficial mutations crabs
grow extra Pinchers Bottom Feeders grow
loger mouths and sharks find themselves
developing heightened senses and even
extra hearts these marine animals seem
to undergo virtually no distress and are
free to exit and re-enter the scp's body
at any point initially SCP
45682 was believed to be the peaceful
one of the pair both serpents seemed to
become active at the same time while on
land SCP
468-1 would wreck havoc with magnitude 7
earthquakes in major metropolitan areas
the sea Serpent's function was less well
understood employing resonant
frequencies and vibrations this SCP was
able to give its watery body a distinct
form as it rose up from the ocean and
towered above the waves in order to
maintain its shape and control its
movements this SCP employed a huge
amount of energy however the foundation
quickly observed that it was rarely able
to maintain its form for very long as
soon as the sea serpent rose out of the
water its mountainous twin would begin
to move sending Tremors around the world
that disrupted the frequency needed for
SCP
45682 to remain animate exhausted and
unable to maintain its shape the sea
serpent would fall into another period
of dorcy gliding lazily through the
oceans but this dorcy suited the
foundation without the constant seismic
Tremors researchers could work fast two
operating bases were set up to monitor
each SCP two mirrored bases with
mirrored teams in constant communication
with one another as soon as one team
made a discovery it was conveyed to the
others and vice versa one operating base
was set up high in the Andes Mountains
specifically designed to be as
earthquake proof as possible capable of
withstanding earthquakes up to 9.9
magnitude meanwhile in the South Pacific
Ocean an underwater Research Center was
built just above the seabed with regular
vessels drifting out into the unknown to
gather whatever data they could about
the great CPS several early findings
stood out firstly SC SCP
468-1 appeared to have a very different
internal structure from its twin
researchers initially assumed that the
creature would be largely composed of
Earth minerals and rock as its exterior
appearance suggested however scans of
its body indicated the presence of what
can only be assumed to be artificially
created components great gears
resembling Clockwork structures and even
rudimentary circuit Tre were present
throughout the creature's body the
function or origin of these gears has
yet to be determined especially as there
is no evident way that their movement
corresponds to the autonomy and movement
of the serpent itself the far more
striking Discovery however came when the
SCP Foundation discovered a way to
communicate with the two beasts Ultra
lowf frequency waves capable of
traveling vast distances even light
years were discovered to be emitted from
the two serpent heads at intermittent
periods the foundation had to develop
some of the largest antenna ever created
to pick up these frequencies and
interpret the data coming through them
what they found were two twins locked in
a fierce debate about the fate of
humanity and the universe itself it was
only then that the motivations of these
two serpents started to make sense in
2010 almost as soon as the foundation
was able to tap into the frequency they
were contacted directly by a CP
468-1 fasion I know that you can hear me
I will not apologize for my actions I
know that I am the reason that millions
of your kind face their demise I know
your pain and I feel it too but I shall
never apologize for it I simply ask you
to listen to myself and to my word
cannot be translated you are curious you
can be patient
exercise that and you may one day
understand and listen the foundation did
efforts to contain or destroy the two
serpents were put on the back burner
instead Foundation agents prioritize
spreading disinformation across South
America and Beyond about the source of
these earthquakes the two serpents are
far too large and far too powerful to
overcome or contain instead the
foundation prioritized the use of
amnestic drugs disinformation and the
creation of Fringe conspiracy groups to
discredit any claims of the serpent
respective existences meanwhile some of
the most senior leadership figures in
the foundation were and still are locked
in a fierce debate as to what to do with
the twin serpents by listening to the
communication between the two scps the
foundation discovered that SCP
45682 is intent on wiping out the entire
human race the only thing that has
prevented it from being being able to do
so thus far has been the existence of
the other serpent every time that SCP
45682 begins to mount an attack on
Humanity its land bearing twin triggers
enormous earthquakes to disrupt its
progress but why would the sea serpent
want to destroy the human race as
Foundation generals gathered in the deep
sea operations base SCP
45682 came to the observation window to
look them in the eyes as it told them I
am sure you can see it how your world
dies a little bit more every day mostly
by your own hand no you poison the
oceans tame the rivers blacken the skies
you do not need angels of death to
destroy your world but there is
something else I see it in the bottom of
your eyes something
Unforgettable unconceivable ideas
cloaked in Madness and impossible colors
do you think I will let you drag the
rest of the world down with
yourselves do you think I will leave
this world my world to Die In Flames it
sees your world and it comes in
fives since this Revelation the
foundation has poured countless hours
and resources into trying to identify a
cosmic threat for well over a decade
many of the smartest scientists the
world has to offer have looked to the
night sky scanning for this impossible
color this shroud of Madness but to no
avail some within the foundation believe
the serpent is lying trying to make up
an excuse to justify its genocide but
information from SCP
468-1 seems to confirm everyone's worst
fears your minds burn bright fion all of
humanity shines from this rock like a
candle in a dark room it sees you an
idea exists only because something
thought of it have you ever considered
how such terrible Concepts could have
been given for what kind of atrocious
mind could even think about it humans
cannot conceive the colorless green what
if you are playing into this creature's
hands there appears to be an underlying
implication that ideas are the source of
power somehow this colorless green this
unimaginable Cosmic threat seems to be a
monstrous idea incarnate but whose idea
Humanities there is a deep lore that the
two serpants discuss with one another
one that makes little sense even to this
day to the foundation they talk of gods
and goddesses deities of Flesh of Steel
and gears and of the fives quite what
these creatures are if they are even
creatures at all is a mystery to the
foundation researchers have not
discovered a way of communicating back
with the two serpents directly attempts
to mimic their language or transmit
signals asking questions to them have
largely been ignored instead they
address humanity and the foundation as a
whole seeming to take the view of the
human race as being a collective hive
mind one that they are evidently able to
tap into the parim uninterested in
informing us as to exactly what this
threat is or explaining who the gods and
goddesses are perhaps they assume we
know these things already or more likely
they believe that our Consciousness is
not yet capable of perceiving the scale
and depth of the concepts that they are
debating what is clear however is their
shared understanding that if Humanity
were to be eliminated the candle was to
be blown out this Cosmic threat would
pass by the hair have names Tren is the
land serpent while remaining dormant
much of the time in an enormous Cave
System beneath the Andes Mountains this
serpent seems Keen to help the
foundation in some way Kai the sea
serpent is intent on sacrificing the
human race for a greater good one far
beyond our understanding speaking to the
foundation in the Andes Mountains
trenten gave a short speech that served
both as encouragement and a terrible
warning of the darkness to come come it
is something I like about you fion about
Mankind while it is easy to just take
the simplest path to just give up there
will always be some among you who refuse
this path who do the right thing maybe
not all of you are this strong but I can
see it in your methods those so-called
containment procedures there will always
be someone who stands up against the
dark even if it takes a thousand million
years to emerge Victorious maybe you can
stop defeat after all ideas can be
killed with better ideas even if it
takes a thousand million years the year
is
1985 16th of February a pair of
researchers aboard a model sm03 deep sea
submersible are descending into the
depths of the Atlantic Ocean hours ago
they were somewhere just off the coast
of France surrounded by Blue Sky the
smell of the Sea and the warm embrace of
the Sun but now only cold Darkness
surrounds them the depth of the ocean so
vast and overwhelming even light could
not Escape its grasp the Twan team are
members of MTF gamma 6 also known as the
Deep feeders a special task force that
specializes in the investigation and
tracking of deep sea or Oceanic
anomalies their mission to locate and
investigate the wreckage of a World War
II German warship known as the bismar
thought by the general public to have
gone down in the naval battle with the
British in
1941 but the story the public doesn't
know is the real reason the pair of
foundation members were tasked with
locating the ship's wreckage site
unfortunately for these researchers
today would be remembered for something
far worse than they had anticipated
radio Transmissions were reported by the
gamma 6 Duo detailed the events that
took place upon finding the bismar
designated SCP
4217 the bismar lay at the bottom of the
ocean partially submerged in the sea
floor but to the astonishment of
researchers it appeared to be perfectly
intact with no signs of damage from its
previous Naval engagements gamma 6
member Charles Miller comments even
after the better part of five decades
this ship is still in pristine condition
there is no water water damage anywhere
that I can see even stranger no ocean
sediment has accumulated on the hole of
the ship whatsoever prompted to
investigate closer agent Victor Miller
begins operation of the crews model rv1
Marine probe an unmanned robotic
exploratory drone that allows the
researchers to explore the interior of
the ship's wreckage what they found
unnerved them or better said what they
didn't find just as the outside of the
vessel appeared free of any corrosion or
wear the interior of the ship was just
as Immaculate the hallways were clean
the walls adorned freshly painted signs
in still legible German even the Nazi
symbols painted onto command centers
still held no sign of disintegration it
was as if the ship had just come off the
assembly line but strangest of all was
the lack of skeletal remains at the time
it was sunk the original crew of the
bismar boasted a minimum of 2,000 men
where were the bodies
continuing the mission the researchers
piloted their unmanned drone down the
Eerie winding corridors along several of
the inner corridors of the submerged
wreckage of SCP
4217 the crew find large thick walls of
what appear to be made out of a
rubberlike substance soon they find that
the large veinlike growths extend
throughout the interior of the ship like
tendrils growing in size the closer the
exploratory drone gets to the center of
the vessel all the while a slight hum
sound is picked up by the Craft's sonar
equipment echoing from the center of the
ship a rhythmic pulsing the crew decide
they need to take a sample of the
rubber-like substance back to Foundation
headquarters for testing this would be a
mistake upon cutting into the thick
tentacle like growths the researchers
noticed something that fills their
stomachs with Dread whatever substance
they had cut into was now bleeding the
team Hears A Distant Rumble growing
steadily louder suddenly the ship begins
to move shuffling sand and debris strew
along the seaf Flor clouding the
visibility of the ship terrified the
pair hurry to try and disconnect the
cable attaching the probe to their
submersible and Evacuate the site but
it's too late a booming thud shakes the
underwater craft as a large Shadow
covers the glass window of the
submersible alarm systems go off as
cracks start to appear in the glass
surface the par attempt to Pilot The
Vessel up towards the surface but they
are halted by a strong force pulling
them downward just as the cracks start
to spread across the surface of the
glass A giant shadow looms over the
submersible what is that screams and the
sound of shattering glass can be heard
on the recording as the submersible
implodes from the pressure of the watery
depths since that unfortunate incident
Foundation members have recorded
multiple occurrences of SCP 4217
attacking civilian cargo ships in the
Atlantic particularly off the coast of
the United Kingdom and as far north as
the Greenland sea given its ker
containment classification containment
of SCP 4217 consists of constant
monitoring by Foundation Naval forces
with the cooperation of the British
royal Navy in episodes of aggression or
an agitated or hostile State Naval
forces are instructed to forcibly subdue
SCP 4217 through Naval engagement once
enough damage is sustained SCP 4217
enters a passive State and resubmerged
scp4 27 is divided into two parts SCP
4217 daa is the bismar itself a Nazi era
warship outfitted with an array of eight
main guns 44 secondary armaments and
dozens of units of anti-aircraft
Weaponry s CP 4217 DB refers to the
anomalous seapod organism embedded
inside the hull of the ship SCP 421 17-b
has two large rectangular pupils inside
of octopod eyes that protrude from the
base of the ship as well as 12 100 to
200 M long tendril-like muscular
appendages that extend outward from an
opening in the stern of the vessel SCP
4217 is deemed to be classification risk
class dangerous with reports of it
emitting a mild psionic field within a
20 km radius confusing anything within
range and increasing the likelihood of
Friendly Fire among enemy combatants SCP
4217 D's Hull seems to have the ability
of inorganic regeneration as damage
incurred from enemy vessels seems to
immaculately repair over time
researchers have observe what appears to
be runes or cryptic markings on the side
of SCP 4217 daa's Hall It is believed
these symbols were part of the original
ship's design to bolster the vessel's
defense Integrity though not immediately
visible when the vessel is taking fire
the symbols appear to Glow in proportion
to the amount of damage being mitigated
among its offens ensive capabilities
apart from the standard armaments of a
World War II era warship SCP 4217 daa
also has specialized Munitions of an
unidentifiable gas compound that is
reported to have mutagenic properties
individuals that have been exposed to
the gas compound undergo rapid
spontaneous metamorphosis at a molecular
level growing an array of evolutionary
attributes which include the
accumulation of reptile-like scales or
Aven feathers in place of skin the
increase or increase of the number of
Limbs digits or even ocular olfactory or
auditory organs and in one reported case
an event where multiple members of One
crew were fused at a subatomic level
into one functioning organism the more
study into this particular incident is
needed SCP 4217 also has the ability of
subsurface Oceanic mobility and can
submerge itself when not in combat with
enemy vessels underwater propulsion
appears to be generated by the ejection
of water from CP 4217 DB's body cavity
and reaches a top speed of approximately
30 knots SCP 427 undergos cycles of
passive behavior that is periodically
interrupted by moments of hostility
towards civilian craft particularly
resurfacing and going after
transatlantic cargo vessels It is
believed this is analogous to the
history and original Mission of the
bismar operation rinen bong during World
War II the German luwa was besieging
London in a series of nightly Air Raids
that would be colloquially known as The
Blitz it was the Grand intention of the
third right to cut off supplies to the
British to limit their resistance to the
Nazi war machine however what pestered
the Nazis most and hindered this effort
was the consistent American Support
provided by the US government in the
form of food and supplies delivered to
the British via Atlantic trade routes by
cargo ship the German bismar and her
sister ship the turits were created for
the very goal of stopping these trans
reports of cargo to the United Kingdom
as well as sinking as many Allied
vessels as possible the year is 1937 in
a top secret effort to make preparations
for an approaching War Adolf Hitler
turns to his most trusted expert on the
supernatural Chief SS officer Heinrich
himler among other projects himler
ordered the anner obscura cor a German
organization tasked with the procurement
and investigation of Otherworldly or
otherwise unexplainable phenomenon to
begin the creation of two ships the
bismar and the turits the former named
after the Iron Chancellor ovon bismar
who in 1890 unified the German people
these vessels were to be created using
recently uncovered technological
Oddities the obscur cor had found in
their studies of the occult sources of
information about the exact creation of
SCP 4217 are highly expunged from the
record but bits and pieces did survive
among what little the foundation was
able to collect and in the records of
the USSR after their occupation of
Eastern German Germany following the
fall of the Nazi regime during the
second world war the earliest mention of
SCP 427's conception dates back to early
1937 when a top secret shipment of
unknown materials labeled component of
thical constructs is intercepted by a
foundation agent working under cover in
a German shipment Center outside of
Hamburg the foundation agent Marcus St
is instructed to maintain surveillance
on the shipment in 1939 upon near
completion of the soon to be christened
bismar a second shipment labeled with
the Insignia of the obscura cor is
intercepted by the foundation agent only
this shipment appears unlike any other
reports of the massive shipping
container holding Machinery capable of
Aquatic Life Support indicate organic
living cargo though the foundation agent
was unable to identify the exact nature
of the contents of the shipment STW
reported hearing sounds emanating from
the cargo hold sounds similar to that of
a heartbeat just a year later the bismar
Markus scene making its first Naval
trial run when it experiences a massive
electrical discharge just offshore
shutting the vessel down momentarily
until power was restored shortly after
reports show luminescent symbols briefly
visible on the hull of the ship
theological symbols for the Layman are
symbols that embodied the study of
Miracles because of this it was apparent
to the foundation that some occult
anomaly was responsible for the strange
characteristics of the German vessel and
an order for termination was reached by
the o Council the hunt for SCP
4217 in the Autumn of 1940 under orders
of neutralization of SCP 4217 all active
Foundation agents presiding in Germany
were ordered to converge on the side of
the bismar to stop the completion of the
vessel but when the time came for the
operation every single one of the
foundation agents vanished no records of
what happened were ever found no
clothing notes not even a trace of their
existence was left behind the mission
was deemed a failure and subsequent
attempts to neutralize SCP 4217 became
far more difficult after the bismar
received a full crew of seamen the fully
manned and well equipped SCP 4217 became
a menace to both military and civilian
Craft on the high seas of the Atlantic
at times appearing without warning
seemingly out of thin air SCP 4217
psionic field obscured it from the new
technological advancements in enemy
radar systems the US government had
development the ship became a shadow on
the Atlantic a subject of ghost stories
for anyone daring to assist the British
government with the war effort
furthermore SCP 4217 did not seem to be
content with the surrender of enemy
vessels captured enemy ships were gassed
turning the men into manufactured beasts
and then sinking the enemy vessels to
the depths of the ocean even submarines
were no match on one report describing
an attempt to elude The Vessel by diving
below the surface only to be intank
Tangled by enormous squid-like
appendages that dragged the craft back
up to the surface before crushing it in
its grasp fearing the safety of the
public the 05 Council decided they could
not stand by and let more innocent lives
be taken they voted to supersede the
foundation's policy on absolute secrecy
to notify the British government of the
danger SCP 4217 pose to Maritime
civilians with cooperation from the
British royal Navy Foundation
Representatives joined the crew of HMS
hood and HMS Prince of Wales to track
reports of the bismar being cited off
the coast of Scandinavia in what history
books would come to know as the Battle
of Denmark Straight HMS hood and HMS
Prince of Wales engaged SCP 4217 and a
secondary German warship known as the
prince Yen confused by the ship's
psionic field the British naval ships
experienced trouble identifying the
bismar and engage in Friendly Fire
before being able to regain control of
their armaments concentrating all volley
of fire on scp4 27 the attack proves
futile as after the Embers and smoke of
Munitions fire wear off the sides of the
bismar hull appear to vibrate with
glowing energy mangled metal begins to
straighten back into perfect frame
breaches and armor begin to heal before
the soldiers very eyes and all that is
left as evidence the ship had ever taken
fire is a cloud of steam emanating from
the hle of SCP
4217 the water surrounding the vessel
began to boil as underwater tentacles
Lurch out and capture the HMS Hood
dragging Her Majesty's ship forward the
men aboard frantically try to regain
control but seconds later are met with
another crisis a salvo of artillery
shells fired from SCP 427's guns hit the
ship severing lines and damaging rail
guns as a mutagenic gas compound starts
to spread among the Royal seamen in mere
minutes the majority of the crew are
engulfed in toxic fumes and experience
vomiting and convulsions their bodies
undergoing rapid involuntary mutagenesis
including the growth of Limbs the
development of fur feathers and scales
in one report it was said that multiple
victims even fused together to create
one single horrifying entity those
exposed to the gaseous compound were
designated SCP
42171 the captain of the HMS Hood
barricades himself inside the helm but
the resulting instances of s SCP 421
17-1 overpower the ship and neutralize
command in the seconds that follow any
witness of the horror that the men
aboard the HMS Hood experienced is
forever inomed in the watery grave of
the British vessel as the ship is sunk
by a volley of Munitions fire from the
combined might of the German Fleet some
men attempting to jump overboard and
swim to safety are dragged down by their
legs by the mutated instances of SCP
4217 and pulled under lungs filling with
seawater as they scream until their
breath is no more in disbelief the crew
of HMS Prince of Wales decided decides
to retreat in the days that followed at
the bequest of foundation members the
British royal Navy launches a fullscale
Armada to hunt down and neutralize the
bismar though SCP 4217 sustained little
damage in the previous encounter the
ship began leaking a black oil-like
substance thought by SCP researchers to
be an organic waste product of SCP 4217
DB the Allied Naval forces are able to
follow the trail to the coast of France
where under the lead of HMS King George
V British warships surround the German
vessel and opened fire this time they
were ready with approval from the 05
Council Foundation members provide the
British forces with enhanced Munitions
and Armament capable of overwhelming SCP
4217 theological defenses on the eve of
battle it appears to the Allied Forces
that the psionic field generated by SCP
4217 is too great as the naval company
find it difficult to land targeted
assaults on the German vessel after
losing several smaller vessels to the
Colossal appendages of SCP
4217 Foundation members on board
authorized the use of a redacted SCP it
is brought in to deactivate SCP 4217
psionic field the tide of The Battle
Turns and after a fierce battle SCP 4217
becomes immobile and unable to return
fire Relentless the British continue
their bombardment until the artillery
Munitions on the ship explode into a
giant Fireball flooding the ship's comp
apartments with the noxious fumes of the
mutogenic compound its crew members
either jump overboard or are engulfed in
the cloud of gas the British vessels
capture any survivors and watch as SCP
4217 slowly sinks below the waves down
to the depths of the ocean where it
would lay dormant for the next 48 years
SCP 427's 121 surviving crew members
were captured and interrogated most of
the low-ranking German soldiers were
released to British custody while 109 of
them having their memory wiped by
Foundation staff 12 remaining members of
the crew were sent to site 23 for
further detention and advanced
interrogation and 74 of the instances of
SCP 421 17-1 the mutated subjects were
recovered and sent to site 23 for
further observation it was thought that
on that day SCP 4217 was deemed
neutralized and no longer a matter of
priority the bismar sunk into memory and
myth the it was only until the recent
Resurgence of SCP 4217 that the
foundation saw the need to collect as
much information on the organism
inhabiting SCP 4217 daa as possible
decades old manuscripts and ledgers were
pulled from hundreds of viable sources
from the intelligence then gathered
Foundation members have come to the
hypothesis that the entity powering the
vessel known as the bismar has what is
believed to be extraplanetary origin
World War II era documents uncovered
between Commander Carl reuter of the
German obscura cor and a doctor Hans
Meyer indicated discovery of an organic
life form of Unknown Origin found in a
crashed aircraft near feldberg Park in
the black forest mountain range in
Germany further correspondence with
obscur cor members OT Schmidt and
Dietrich clner indicate that researchers
were conducting trials on the creatures
ability to create psionic fields and to
control or confuse enemy subjects within
its range with a letter from dietr clner
suggesting the creature could be used as
a power source for an unspecified engine
further evidence of SCP 4217 DB's
extraplanetary origin can be found in a
1993 incident between Foundation naval
ship scps nemed and SCP
4217 this is the only incident on record
where contact was established with the
creature classified as SCP 4217 DB on
July 22nd SCP 427 had reappeared off the
coast of Britain anticipating hostility
scps nemed scps cesir and scps partholon
were instructed to close in on SCP 427's
location with orders to subdue The
Vessel if necessary however on this
occasion SCP 4217 did not appear to be
after any vessel it was simply drifting
along at Sea no propulsion engines
active noticing the change in SCP 4217
Behavior Captain Kurt Wagner decided to
withhold military engagement and
investigate SCP 427's Behavior sailing
within 200 M of the bismar the scps
nemid attempted radio contact with the
German vessel after repeated attempts at
communication the crew were met with
only silence and static chatter giving
up Captain Wagner puts down the radio
receiver when suddenly the sound of
music is heard playing over the speakers
of a ship the tune is the national
anthem of Nazi Germany the captain
hailes The Vessel again repeating his
attempts at communication do you do you
understand me at first only static can
be heard then came a reply you
ship the ominous voice could be heard
from the speakers the captain hesitated
for a moment members of The Crew looking
at each other with apprehension the
captain replied confirming themselves as
a ship and then asking if as SCP 427
knew what it was and where it came from
what followed was the crew of the scps
nemed receiving a video feed from SCP
4217 featuring a high volume of images
in Rapid succession among them were
images of German cities Adolf Hitler's
telecast of the 1936 Olympics an unknown
structure in outer space and an
increasing repetition images of the
planet Jupiter particularly the giant
storm on Jupiter known to the public as
the Great Red Spot or SCP 2399 as
Foundation members know it the
transcript of the radio communication
between Captain Wagner and SCP 2417
stops when the video feed begins to
focus heavily on images of Jupiter SCP
427's responses become more erratic and
agitated as it repeats the words storm
cloud and red the markings on its hole
beginning to light up and the underwater
Shadows of its tentacles beginning to
create whirlpools of displacement under
the the bow of the ship a shrill
shrieking begins to flood out of the
speakers followed by a high piercing
high pitched beeping sound that
overloads the communication equipment
causing Sparks to fly as crew members
cover their ears and hide under control
panels the scps nemed barely escapes as
SCP 4217 becomes hostile using its
massive tendril-like appendages to
assail the naval combatants firing its
Armament in all directions after a
fierce battle the foundation Naval
forces were able to neutralize and
subdue SCP
4217 no further attempts at
communication have been recorded to keep
the veil of secrecy Foundation members
constructed a replica ship to be sunk
and intentionally rediscovered by
oceanographer Robert Ballard in
1989 any recent sightings of the Nazi
era Bismark are flagged as
misidentification by SCP staff for now
Foundation members continue to monitor
the behavior of SCP
4217 and protect the public
from its existence a giant monstrous
craba likee claw closes around the
throat of an unimaginably huge eel-like
Beast the beast's terrible writhing
tentacles wrap around and latch onto the
immense crustation and then the
high-intensity beams of gamma radiation
start flying all the while Legions of
skinless Centaur swim in the waters
around them relishing the violence and
in the middle a lone boat The scps
mither Man by a team of mobile task
force operatives that does all it can
just to survive there are those who
consider outer space to be the ultimate
achievement in Exploration the one place
that explorers have yet to chart and
understand however some of the murkiest
Mysteries in the universe are on our own
Planet deep down at the bottom of the
ocean 95% of the deep ocean remains
completely unexplored and the little
glimpses we have gotten paint a picture
of something truly alien giant squids
organisms that can breathe nitrogen
luminescent predatory fish and sharks as
old as the Earth itself even the SCP
Foundation is still struggling to fully
grasp the depth of the ocean and the
strange beings that dwell there one of
the most unusual aquatic findings in the
history of the foundation is that of SCP
37 00 SCP 3700 refers to a circular area
in the North Sea with a diameter of 800
km the waters there are abnormally deep
for the region with the seafloor resting
at 5 km beneath the ocean's surface
there are two entities present in the
waters of SCP 3700 designated SCP 3700
D1 and SCP
37002 interactions between these two
entities are responsible for the anomal
changes to the meteorological and
geological conditions in the area SCP
37001 and SCP
37002 always interact on the spring and
fall equinoxes of Any Given year but
they will also engage one another
throughout the year seemingly at random
but what exactly are SCP
37001 and SCP
37002 aside from terrifying creatures of
the deep scp3 7001 is an arthropod
bearing an aesthetic resemblance to the
European Lobster only much much bigger
measuring 6 km in length the creature is
green with a mix of blue yellow pink and
red markings across the top of its
exoskeleton that bear the appearance of
a woman's face it has six prehensile
limbs four of which terminate in Claws
and eight legs the entities four eyes
are compound and orange attached to
stalks anyone who gets close enough to
observe the creature's carpes in detail
will notice scars cracks and small holes
indicating years and years of damage SCP
37001 has several anomalous qualities in
addition to its size in a fight it is
able to strike with its appendages and
produce cavitation bubbles with a force
greater than several tons of Dynamite
two of the entities eyes are capable of
blasting concentrated G radiation at a
chosen Target the creature has the
ability to impact the weather around it
dispersing storms that impede its
ability to move with ease and can reach
speeds up to 100 km an hour in spite of
its immense power SCP
37-1 is not aggressive and tends to
ignore beings in its vicinity other than
SCP 3700 D2 speaking of SCP 3700 D2 it
is a 32 km long entity resembling a
pelican eel in all aspects except for
its massive size and the 13 appendages
that encircle the middle section of its
body these appendages which tuck inside
its body when not in use are similar to
the tentacles of an octopus complete
with suckers the majority of the
entity's body consists of a seny tail
terminating in a sharp point when its
mouth is open it is an estimated 3 km
deep its flesh is black and it has white
purple and red bioluminescent lines in
the shape of a man's face on either side
of its torso SCP 3700 d2's anomalous
properties include the ability to invoke
storms with a severity of category 5
hurricanes and the ability to produce
whirlpools that draw in any vessel
within 150 M so that it can rip them
apart it is also able to produce high
energy sound waves as well as blue fire
which it emits from its esophagus when
the two entities interact it results in
an epic struggle as each begins attempts
to destroy or subdue the other when one
is Victorious immediate changes to the
area follow when SCP 37001 wins the
storms and harsh weather in the area
will immediately calm and an era of
fertility and abundance will begin the
reproductive rates of fauna in the ocean
and on the islands nearby increase
threefold and the crop yield doubles the
ocean itself becomes increasingly active
and the erosion rates of the
archipelago's shores increase 5-fold
when SCP 37002 wins however the weather
conditions become dangerous with raging
hurricanes rapidly fluctuating
temperatures and constantly changing
Storm fronts that cause destruction of
buildings and loss of life naturally
this renders any Ocean Travel in the
area extremely difficult or even
impossible aquatic food sources are
driven Away by harsh conditions and
livestock are killed by exposure and
disease crops are unable to thrive in
the high winds water log soil and lack
of sunlight all the while SCP 37002
swims throughout the area praying on
unsuspecting ships and menacing the
coastline until SCP 37001 manifests to
challenging again SCP 37002 will also
regurgitate instances of SCP
3456 though how or why this is possible
is unknown for those unfamiliar with SCP
3456 they are a group of hairless
three-toed horike creatures with thick
translucent skin and human torsos fused
to their backs they are most frequently
seen near sights of War terrorist
attacks and devastating natural disas
disasters direct observation of one of
these entities will draw their attention
to the Observer who the entity will then
stalk and capture before disappearing
due to their enormous size and ability
to anomalously manifest in their home
Waters SCP
37-1 and two cannot be contained at a
foundation site instead their
containment is handled by Foundation
Naval task force Delta 7 Northern Storm
who Patrol the area in combination of
refurbished battle ships destroyers
Cruisers and support craft additionally
measures have been taken to suppress
information about SCP 3700 among the
general population details about the
unusual depth of the waters there have
been stricken from public texts and
scientific Publications SCP 37001 has
been implanted with donovian Hollow
projectors which disguise it as a pod of
humpback whales if SCP 37001 encounters
SC p3700 D2 Delta 7 May engage protocol
winter Maelstrom this consists of
Destroyers deploying Harpoon based
anchors into SCP 3700 d2's head to hold
it in one location next the vessels work
together to Target The Entity until SCP
37001 is able to subdue it if this does
not prove effective and SCP
37002 cannot be contained then the task
force will Implement protocol tumult at
this point Naval and civilian crafts in
the area must be evacuated trade and
Ferry routes to the archipelagos must be
rerouted for at least 6 months there
will be constant aerial and Naval
engagement with SCP
37002 and constant monitoring for the
reappearance of SCP
37001 the behavior of SCP 37001 and SCP
37002 is largely very predictable with
one notable exception on March 20
2017 a pair of SCP foundation- owned
battleships known as the mither and the
Teran arrived at a point between the
orne Shetland and Pharaoh archipelagos
in the North Sea they were accompanied
by the usual Fleet of Delta 7 ships
approximately 600 M away from the ship's
anchor points the water began to emit
intense bright rays of light for a
duration of 3 minutes at this point SCP
37001 appeared visible through the
surface of the water Delta 7 withdrew
their anchors speeding toward the entity
as the ships caught up to the entity it
raised two of its claws into the air
clicking them together in a friendly
greeting the Delta 7 ships followed the
entity along its usual swimming path for
30 minutes and during this time all was
peaceful but this peace did not endure
for long the tide began to change
literally as large black wall clouds
formed overhead the winds picked up and
the waves churned violently in response
SC SCP 37001 raised its claws overhead
waving them in a circular motion and
parting the clouds above it and Delta 7
but this effort took a lot out of the
creature and after 30 seconds its
antenna began to droop and it lowered
its claws still the hole in the clouds
remained allowing a spot of sunshine to
break through and beam down on the
foundation vessels 600 M ahead the ocean
waters began to rage and froth spraying
foam and surf into the air SCP 37002
burst from beneath the surface its head
pointed upward it continued to rise
until the tops of its tentacles could be
seen just above the water then stopped
to bend its torso and turn its head
horizontally its jaw unhinged exposing
rows upon rows of serrated teeth the
Beast L out a mighty Roar accompanied by
a stream of blue flame at the sight of
its rival SCP 37001 Dove beneath the
surface disappearing from view the scps
mither ordered the rest of the vessels
to engage protocol winter Maelstrom
Delta 7 scattered out from SCP 3700 d1's
point of submersion and all 13
destroyers fired their harpoons at SCP
3700-3 embedding themselves in the
entity's head naturally this enraged the
creature and it began to Roar and whale
spinning its lower body vigorously
enough to generate a Whirlpool the
Cruisers opened fire with a combination
of L cannons and conventional Weaponry
in order to distract The Entity as the
Destroyers pulled their Harpoon lines
tot dragging its head in a continuous
Circle while this was taking place the
battleships got into position and
prepared to fire on the mither's Mark 3
2 1 fire the first broadside barrage
collided with SCP 3700 D2 and it grunted
in pain thrashing back and forth before
opening its mouth and spewing an
instance of SCP 3456 into the water as
soon as it hit the water the eoin
monster began to cut through at a pace
of 50 km an hour making its way toward
the Destroyers particularly the scps
skki the skki attempted to retarget its
weapons and prevent the creature from
reaching it but the monster moved too
quickly for the sky to adjust the sky
was lifted out of the water by the
creature as crew members desperately CL
clung to the railings and their Weaponry
as the crew cowered and tried to fend
off the creature it reached for them
trying to pull them from the ship while
the sky was occupied SCP 3700 D2 was
able to attack again blasting another
ship with a stream of blue fire a loud
crack rang out from across the sea as
the sky dropped back into the water the
SCP 3456 instant shrieking in pain SCP
37001 burst through the surface striking
the creature with its Club likee limbs
each blow emitting another loud crack
the third blow tore the instance in half
sending its human torso kening through
the air and past the scps mither freed
from its attack the CI moved full steam
ahead pulling the Harpoon line TD again
and dragging SCP
37002 out of its path several silky crew
members were thrown overboard during the
struggle and as they struggled to keep
their heads above water SCP 37 700 D1
scooped them up placing them onto the
deck of a nearby destroyer and out of
Harm's Way with the crew members rescued
as CP 37001 set its sights on its enemy
swimming towards the edge of the
whirlpool and emitting a luminescent
glow from two of its eyes the constant
barrage of cannon fire on SCP 37002 was
beginning to take its toll and the
mither ordered the fleet to quote brace
for the killing blow as if responding to
the mither's call SCP 3700 D1 shot
several concentrated blasts of gamma
radiation at its foe leaving large holes
in the creature in their wake SCP 37002
screamed flailing so hard that it
snapped the Harpoon lines and created
waves large enough to push the vessels
backward with its Newfound Freedom SCP
37002 impaled SCP 37001 through the
midsection with its Barbed tip of its
tail lifting it up and out of the water
with a force of the blow SCP 37001
desperately tried to free itself
attacking the tail with its Club likee
limbs but the fight was in vain and
after a moment all movements stopped SCP
37001 was for at least the duration of
this manifestation dead SCP 37002 tossed
the corpse into the water flinging it
past Delta 7 where it crashed into the
water and sank down Into the Depths
below at this point Delta 7 was ordered
to initiate protocol tumult the Delta 7
vessels turned away from SCP
37002 and prepared to evacuate the area
one of the ships the scps stren Beast
slowed behind the rest of the fleet
emitting concerning amounts of smoke
before coming to a stop meanwhile the
enraged and emboldened SCP
37002 expanded the size of its Whirlpool
setting its sights on the retreating
ships and the weakened strawy Beast the
ship tried to flee but the engines were
completely shot and would not respond
the ship was caught in the whirlpool and
pulled against its will toward SCP
37-2 as the crew looked on in helpless
dread a tentacle Rose from the deep
wrapping around the vessel and dragging
it toward the entity gaping ma suddenly
SCP 37001 exploded from beneath the
surface of the water leaping between the
ship and SCP
37002 cutting the tentacle in half and
free the sty beast from its grip SCP
3700 D2 shrieked before closing its jaws
and biting down on SCP
300-1 it retaliated emitting bright
flashes of light and doing enough damage
to stop SCP 3700 D2 from continuing to
produce its Whirlpool another tentacle
emerged from the water pulling at SCP
37001 legs and ripping them from its
body but SCP 37001 returned the assault
in kind bludgeoning SC CP 37002 with its
Club likee limbs from inside of its
mouth all at once SCP 3700 d2's lower
jaw was torn out of place dropping into
the water with SCP 37001 still inside
SCP 3700 D2 thrashed fuly growing
steadily weaker and weaker it released
one more stream of fire before
collapsing Delta 7 paused The Retreat
watching the scene for any sign of a
winner but after 5 minutes neither
entity had moved Delta 7 returned to the
side of the battle to investigate and
saw that neither entity was moving and
both appeared to be deceased shortly
after Delta 7 reached the area both
entities disappeared leaving a single
round unidentified object that sank
below the surface where SCP
37001 had just been the wall clouds
overhead dispersed leaving standard cumo
nimbus clouds in their place the waters
themselves remained shoppy unsure of how
to proceed the scps mither sent a radio
transmission to command ah this is Delta
7 to command we read you delta7 command
replied we have a bit of a situation go
ahead Delta 7 SCP
37001 and two are both down command was
silent for 10 seconds utterly baffled by
the information please repeat Delta 7
again the myther said SCP
37001 and two are both dead down command
ordered the myther to stand by 3 minutes
of radio silence later communication
resumed as they asked are either
entities effects active ah negative
command is there any trace of either
entity also negative it appears the
anomaly has been neutralized Delta 7 is
to return to base for debrief following
any recovery efforts with their next
steps clear Delta 7 attached the stra
bees to several tugboats preparing to
pull the vessel to safety but the there
was one more surprise waiting the scps
mither began picking up unusual levels
of gamma radiation as well as a sonar
contact at a depth of 3 km they called
command requesting permission to deploy
submersibles for exploration purposes 1
minute of Silence followed as the
command arrived at a decision request
denied return to base for debriefing and
so Delta 7 began to evacuate the area
once more steaming in the opposite
direction of the battle over the next 5
minutes minutes CCTV cameras on the
vessels picked up an unusual sight as
the gamma radiation levels continued to
increase the ocean turbulence also
worsened tossing smaller vessels and
nearly causing them to capsize then all
of a sudden the water stilled and four
large yellow orbs appeared below the
surface approximately 300 M from Delta 7
they lingered there for 2 minutes before
Vanishing afterward a new sonar contact
was detected 5 km deep directly beneath
the task force command we've lost the
signal from the previous contact and are
no longer detecting gamma radiation uh
we're detecting new contact 5 km deep
large and metallic after further
deliberation command responded Delta 7
you are authorized to deploy
submersibles for exploration purposes be
advis should SCP 37002 manifest
exploration teams are to be considered
lost and you are to return to base the
consequences of this incident as well as
what else might be lurking down in the
depths beneath SCP 3700 are still
unknown hello SCP Foundation Personnel
welcome to Cognito hazards and you
episode redacted this video series is
intended to teach you about the protocol
surrounding the various Cognito
hazardous anomalies currently within
Foundation containment when you know
better you do better and both you and
the secrets of our great organization
can stay safe and as anyone familiar
with the good Cognito Hazard can tell
you knowing really can make a difference
today's episode is about the unique and
dangerous SCP
2316 before we begin repeat after me and
be sure to speak clearly into the
microphone in front of you I do not
recognize the Bodies In The Water a
little louder please thank you in order
to be educated about the following SCP
you must pass a vocal examination with a
cognitive resistance value of no less
than
14.5 through this video presentation you
will need to repeat the phrase to ensure
your score does not drop below the
approved threshold in the event that you
fail the test stay calm and remain where
you are until medical staff can retrieve
you remember safety is a top priority
when observing Cognito hazards the safe
way is the only way you're a cog in a
very important machine and we wouldn't
want to have to terminate you now would
we one more time please I do not
recognize the Bodies In The Water very
good remember that you do not recognize
them no matter what you might think you
see your thoughts can be very unreliable
when you're around SCP
2316 according to our files on the
matter SCP 2316 refers to an anomalous
phenomenon identified in a Small Town
Lake it appears as a collection of human
bodies floating in a group on the
surface of the water the exact number of
corpses is unknown but it has been
estimated to be anywhere between 45 and
200 though the bodies belong to
individuals many researchers theorize
that the bodies in the water which you
do not recognize and you have never
recognized share a collective
Consciousness they function it would
seem with a hive mind of sorts the
bodies do not act on their own but as
one now where does the Cognito Hazard
come into play it would seemen that
anyone who looks at the bodies in the
water or learns too much about SCP 2316
as a whole begins to believe the corpses
floating in the lake are people they
recognize perhaps they remember their
faces from childhood or High School
whatever the case may be they become
convinced that the bodies in the water
are familiar and that they must approach
them no matter how familiar they might
seem however you do not recognize the
Bodies In The Water if a person attempts
to enter the lake reaching out to
whatever instances of SCP 2316 they
think they recognize more bodies will
begin to appear the more bodies appear
the more familiar faces seem to manifest
and the deeper the person will venture
into the lake eventually the person is
lost within the Sea of bodies likely
drowning beneath the surface or simply
becoming one with the hive mind until
they too are one of the corpses there
none of the individuals who wandered
into the lake in search of an old friend
or classmate have ever been recovered
there have been no attempts to search
the lake for their bodies as it is
unknown what effect SCP 2316 would have
on the team assigned to such a task
though we can guess that the outcome
would likely be extremely negative for
all involved those who do Venture into
the lake simply disappear never to be
seen again if you look too long at the
bodies in the lake perhaps their faces
would surface alongside the rest but
it's best not to think about that after
all we do not recognize the Bodies In
The Water Foundation Personnel are not
allowed to approach SCP 2316 under any
circumstances the lake is only permitted
to be observed via dummy probes
outfitted with video and audio recording
equipment no one is permitted to observe
any footage or audio files collected
unless they pass through a screening for
resilience to Cognito hazardous
anomalies the lake that holds SCP 236
has been fenced off and is patrolled by
guards with no prior knowledge of or
exposure to SCP
2316 anyone who attempts to approach the
lake and break through the boundaries of
its quarantine will be seized and taken
to site 33 for examination anyone who
comes within 50 m of the lake is
considered lost and presumed dead repeat
after me slowly and clearly into the
microphone I do not recognize the bodies
in the water good
I almost believe you let's continue only
one Foundation officer that entered the
lake containing SCP 2316 was ever
stopped before they could be lost their
name has been stricken from any official
records and you do not need to know it
their identity does not matter what
matters is the interview they gave
following the incident conducted by Dr
Harrison in his office Dr Harrison asked
the anonymous officer if they felt
compelled to enter the Water by an
invisible force
as if pulled in they rejected this
concept entirely insisting that they
entered the water of their own free will
they wanted to see the bodies who
appeared to them as their friends they
wanted to hear what the bodies were
saying upon entering the water they saw
the faces of their friends other faces
were unfamiliar but became more familiar
the longer the officer stared at their
features these were faces they had known
their entire life but something about
them was just a little bit wrong
it was like the face of someone in a
dream where you can tell they are
someone you know and you can even
identify who it is supposed to be but
something about them does not quite look
right your mind could not perfectly put
their face together from memory even
though the feeling of familiarity
Remains the faces in the water peering
up through the darkness below were like
those dream addled Memories the faces in
the water did not open their mouths but
somehow they spoke to the officer just
the same they spoke of who they were and
asked for help they asked to be seen to
be touched they spoke of the foundation
accusing us of covering up their deaths
and keeping the world from remembering
what happened to them at this point in
the interview the subject became
agitated yelling at Dr Harrison and
refusing to be quiet guards intervened
holding the subject still as they fought
yelling at Dr Harrison repeating over
and over that they could hear the body
speaking to them every single one the
interview ended when the guards removed
the subject from the room taking them to
the amnestics department to have all
memory of the Bodies In The Water erase
from their mind then they were forgotten
once more I do not recognize the Bodies
In The Water did you repeat it good we
do not recognize the Bodies In The Water
we can't the motivations of SCP 2316 if
it has any at all are largely unclear
there are those on the research staff
that theorize the hive mind or
Collective consciousness of the bodies
is not malevolent in nature it is they
believe simply trying to make sure that
a tragedy that occurred in that lake is
remembered perhaps many lives were lost
to an anomalous force in that Lake and
the impact of that massive tragedy left
behind an impression on the location
this impression manifests s in the form
of bodies spontaneously appearing in an
impossibly well preserved condition the
Cognito Hazard of SCP 2316 is not
intended to kill anyone or take them but
rather to force strangers to remember
the people who lost their lives to the
lake this sense of familiarity whether
it is false or not ensures that the dead
will not be forgotten or left alone
after all no one deserves to be left
alone though there have been lives lost
to the Cognito Hazard according to the
foundation it is understandable why the
bodies would want to be recognized to
have someone somewhere know who they
were to have someone remember their
names Jeremiah Fineman Arthur Scott
Denise
Clark where was I oh yes repeat after me
once again I do not recognize the bodies
in the water I do not recognize them I
do
not but that's a lie isn't it I do
recognize them how could I not I know
them they're my friends do you recognize
them look at their faces don't fight the
memories look into their eyes the class
of 1975 they were supposed to graduate
that fall they were just kids group of
innocent kids lost to the dark and deep
what happened to them I can't quite
remember but I know that it mattered
enough for the foundation to keep the
secret secret and I know that somehow I
survive but I shouldn't have I should be
there with them I should be there there
isn't much time I can hear the guards
coming to retrieve me their footsteps
thundering down the hall I failed the
test and the alarm has gone off they
think I'm lost but I'm not I've never
been less lost in my entire life I've
finally woken up to the truth I remember
I have to go I have to return to the
lake fall of 1975 they went for a swim
my friends calling to me I can hear them
so clearly even from so far away their
cries for help ringing in my ears their
voices curling around me pulling me to
the edge of the water the guards will
come for you too they'll know you've
seen this they'll call you compromised
they'll say I succumb to the effects of
the Cognito Hazard they'll say you did
too you'll fail their little test and
they'll say that makes you weak and
broken but you cannot listen they're
lying it's not a hazard it's a scream
for help they they're screaming and the
foundation keeps covering it up they
won't let us find them and they won't
tell us why I have to go back so we can
be together again there are signs posted
all around the lake danger drowning
Hazard those are a trick it's to keep me
out to to keep the truth from me the
barbwire fences around it it's just
another trick I'll climb over it rung
after rung I don't care if the barbs
tear my clothes or pierce my skin it's
worth it for the truth for the memory
and once I've climbed to the top I'll be
able to see there through the fog I can
see their faces their lips parted in a
constant cry their eyes wide looking for
me my friends my family every face
unlocking a memory long buried I know
them all and I must go further I can't
turn back now I have to wade into the
water let its chills soak into my
clothes down pound to my bones one step
and another deeper and deeper the water
lapping at my ankles my knees my thighs
the deeper I go the more sure I will be
that this is where I belong the water
will engulf my chest my neck until my
feet no longer touch the ground I will
be lost in it water flooding into my
mouth pouring into every opening I will
let my body sink down down down to the
bottom where they've been all this time
nestled in the dirt and the dust they've
been so patient but it's finally time
they're ready to be remembered to be
seen to be found they're waiting for me
and they're waiting for you too can you
hear them I'm going now you have to find
me you have to follow me don't let the
guards stop you don't let them wipe it
all away from your mind fight break free
and find the lake hop the fence make
your way into the water you can't leave
leave me there to fade away floating in
the cold with the rest can you hear us
we're waiting Jack was swimming deep
underwater wondering why he had such a
pounding headache when suddenly he had a
terrifying realization he had no idea
where he was or what he was doing there
was a nagging feeling that he must have
a specific reason to be here you don't
just end up deep in the ocean with a
diving suit on by chance yet he had no
idea what he was supposed to be doing he
wasn't sure he cared either he was more
worried about a throbbing pain in his
head and the vision of two eyes staring
at him out of the dark that he couldn't
get out of his mind his heart began to
race as he wondered what to do and how
to get help he was in the middle of the
ocean and appeared to be all alone he
couldn't see anything in the Dark Water
except for this weird gray substance in
front of him maybe he was going to die
here alone without knowing if anyone
could even hear him he began to speak
aloud about how he was consumed by
sickness and that Darkness was all
around him this is the story of one of
the most powerful and dangerous
anomalies yet discovered SCP 3000 before
Jack's descent into despair the SCP
Foundation had mandated an exploratory
Expedition off the coast of Bangladesh
after receiving a few strange reports
from locals and fishermen the foundation
suspected an SCP was lurking in the
water and positioned a few Personnel to
investigate the crew expected danger or
maybe even death but what they got
instead was Far stranger and more
ominous all of the men had been verified
to be in sound mental States when the
mission set out but a few of them
reported feeling strange and uneasy as
the submarine descended into the ocean
before long a veteran agent named Dr
Williams began to panic in a way that
was completely out of character he
started sweating profusely shaking and
wouldn't listen to a word of comfort or
reason that anybody tried to offer it
might seem like a relatively normal
reaction for anyone descending into the
depths of the ocean to meet with a
monster that they don't know anything
about but Dr Williams was a seasoned
professional who had been on hundreds of
such missions before there was no
logical reason for to act like this
although the reaction of Dr Williams was
the most extreme he wasn't the only one
who started to feel strange multiple
agents developed a creeping feeling of
unease that swept over them one of the
calmer men tried to reason with Dr
Williams asking him what was wrong and
if he could explain exactly how he was
feeling that's when things got even
stranger Not only was the doctor
extremely anxious but he now seemed
incapable of giving a real response to
any questions thrown at him he could
only mutter that he was missing
something but he wasn't sure what
knowing that many scps can bend reality
and the human mind many of the Personnel
began to have second thoughts about the
mission and even asked for permission to
call off the mission but they were
mandated to continue so they went on as
the team went deeper and deeper into the
ocean things only got worse even the
previously calm crew members became
spooked and antsy while the ones who
were already anxious were now sweating
and jittering as for Dr Williams he was
now pacing back and forth around the
submarine saying things nobody could
understand every every time he looked at
his colleagues and his close friends he
seemed to stare straight through them
and would call them by the wrong names
it was as if his mind had moved to a
different dimension whenever someone
asked him to perform his normal duties
he looked more confused than ever still
the team went deeper Dr Williams began
to whimper and say the word no
repeatedly growing louder and louder
until he was screaming and the others
were forced to sedate him just then
something came into view it was what
would come to be known as SCP 300
the thing was huge so huge that its
whole body couldn't be seen out of the
submarine window it was a horrible eel
looking creature with a head as big as a
town and haunting eyes that Lit Up The
Black Ocean around it but perhaps the
strangest part was this giant eel seemed
to be producing a weird gray liquid even
the sedative wasn't enough to keep Dr
Williams calm anymore there was a
strange blank look in his eyes as if the
light and life had left him and he just
began screaming no repeatedly again and
wouldn't respond to any attempts to calm
him down not that anyone else was very
capable of calming him down at this
point even the crew members that had
been holding up well were starting to
act strangely and nobody could get the
image of these ominous eyes out of their
heads then things went from bad to worse
Williams began screaming and shouting
madly as if he was being tortured by an
unseen Force the men tried to restrain
him but it was no use he began smashing
his head against the submarine window
until it cracked putting the whole
mission in everyone's life at risk he
felt to the ground injured chanting that
there was nothing whatever that meant it
was an emergency scenario they began
applying first aid to Williams as the
submarine ascended to the surface as
quickly as possible before the pressure
of the ocean caused the cracked window
to explode by the time they reached the
surface Williams was dead but there was
something even more chilling than the
circumstances of his death every single
man who had been in that submarine
experienced the same thing on the days
that came afterward the image of the
eel-like creatur's eyes seemed burned in
their minds permanently it would haunt
their waking hours for the rest of their
lives and sleep was no Escape either as
they would appear in both their dreams
and nightmares alike forever a second
mission had to be sent to gather more
information about the strange Beast
already there were many theories and
question marks surrounding SCP 3000 how
big was it really was it sentient what
was the liquid for none of the men who
had been on the previous Mission were
willing to return to the waters but a
new group of Brave recruits volunteered
they were about to find out what so many
in history have learned the hard way
that bravery and foolishness are often
mistaken for the same thing this time
the mission would not be in a submarine
but in dive suits in order to observe
the anomaly in even closer detail and to
eliminate the chance of one team member
self-sabotaging the submarine killing
them all they were transported to the
location by boat and the three men
splashed into the ocean they descended
and at first everything was going well
in case anything went wrong the three of
them were tethered together for extra
security but the deeper into the ocean
they swam and the the closer they got to
SCP 3000's location they got the
stranger things became just like on the
last mission first there were a few
minor cases of confusion one of the team
Jack thought it was his responsibility
to lead the navigation but another
Roberto also thought it was his job in
fact navigation was actually the job of
a third team member Amir but he seemed
to have forgotten everyone was getting
confused the team listening in on the
conversations at the foundation
headquarters grew increasingly concerned
about what they could hear was everyone
losing their Minds hopefully nobody was
about to pull another Dr Williams on
them still the project leads couldn't
afford to tell the men to come back to
the surface the foundation badly needed
any information they could get on this
SCP whatever the cost so they told the
men to press on things only got worse
Roberto was asking to speak to a
colleague who passed away two years ago
while the others began to mutter
indistinguishable phrases about eyes and
darkness not too dissimilar to the
ramblings of Dr Williams it increasingly
began to look like a suicide mission
then there was silence what was going on
each of the men had completely lost it
to the point that they cut the tether
that was holding them together all alone
Jack couldn't remember where he was or
why he was here he desperately looked
around to try and gauge his surroundings
but he could only see Darkness all he
could think about was a pair of large
eyes and an overwhelming fear of Despair
and anxiety and this weird gray fluid
that was now floating in front of him
the foundation listened as Jack started
reciting a creepy speech about being on
the edge of nothing inch from Oblivion
with a sickness in his mind and nothing
but a pair of eyes in front of him they
listened in horror as they heard
movement through the radio it sounded
like a huge creature was swimming toward
the men it had to be SCP 3000 but all
three men were too confused to do
anything about the situation or to even
see what was in front of them claiming
they couldn't see anything in the
darkness there was silence for half a
minute with the team listening in
fearing the worst then they heard some
more unintelligible mutterings the men
must be alive but what on Earth was
going going on then the gibberish
started again two of the men were
screaming that Jack had just been
swallowed whole and that they were being
sucked in too why couldn't they just
swim away it was chaos but then a few
moments later Roberto spoke into the
radio saying he was floating alone in
the middle of the ocean and had now
moved away from the eyes of SCP 3000 he
finally seemed capable of forming
coherent thoughts and speech after what
had just happened Roberto now had a
theory he thought that somehow it was
impossible to think straight around SCP
3000 when he'd been close enough to see
the eyes Roberto had felt a throbbing
pain in his brain and been unable to
think about anything perhaps it was
something to do with that mysterious
gray liquid even more slime was coming
out of SCP 3000 now and Roberto was
determined to get a sample despite the
warnings from HQ in one final burst of
motivation he swam close enough to take
some of the gray liquid and put it in a
special sample collection unit that was
designed to float to the surface for
collection later he had acquired some
very important data but he seemed to
have lost all hope of preserving his
life Roberto started telling the team
over the radio that he was dying and
that his heart rate was too high but
cautioned that it would be too dangerous
for anyone to try and rescue him the
Personnel continued to try and
communicate with Roberto to figure out
what was going on but his words had
stopped making any sense until finally
he went quiet minutes turned into hours
hours into days and still there was no
sign of Roberto or the rest of the
divers after 3 days His Radio which had
only been sending a steady stream of
Static finally stopped working
altogether and he was presumed dead
however the sample Roberto had collected
had survived and made it to the hands of
the foundation researchers it turned out
to be a viscous substance now known as
y99 a chemical compound and extremely
strong anesthesia y 99 causes head pain
paranoia fear Panic memory loss and
confusion explaining what happened to Dr
Williams and the diving Trio the
collection of Y 99 might have resulted
in two disastrous missions but there's a
silver lining as the substance ended up
becoming an invaluable tool for the SCP
Foundation its ability to make people
forget what had just happened to them
can be used to eliminate knowledge of
threatening scps among the public it
also helps the foundation staff cope
with the traumatic experiences they
encounter on their missions although
other amnestics can be used for the same
purpose none are as powerful as the one
produced by SCP 3000 before its
Discovery the amnestics used would break
down too quickly not farewell in storage
or cause undesirable side effects the
only problem is the method of sourcing
the only way to obtain y 99 is somewhat
ethically questionable for most people
SCP 3000 produces y99 after eating so
the best way to stock up on it is by
feeding the creature sedated d-class
Personnel from the foundation are sent
on Mission supposedly to observe the
anomaly up close unaware that this
mission is one way only other divers are
then sent later to collect the fluid
from a safe distance and store it of
course it's all for the greater good of
humanity now the foundation protects SCP
3000 as best as it can guard something
hundreds of kilometers long the area is
carefully patrolled and members of the
public are not allowed to enter the part
of the bay where it resides anybody who
accidentally comes into contact is
contained eventually another pair of
foundation doctors went down in a
submarine to try and learn more about
SCP 3000 one became so affected by y 99
that he began hallucinating he started
talking about ananta shesha the king of
serpents in Hinduism anant shesha is
believed to be all that will be left
after the end of the world because it
exists throughout all of time
simultaneously the doctor said he
believed that this was in fact an anesa
that SCP 3000 simply shows us that
eventually everyone dies and Fades into
the darkness of Oblivion right before he
exited the submarine and swam right into
his mouth luckily for now SCP 3000 seems
to be in a sort of hibernation state it
rarely moves and it doesn't hunt
although it will eat when fed but no one
knows when or if it'll wake or what it's
capable of if it does will it destroy
the world or simply drive us all insane
the ocean is is a terrifying Place we've
all heard the statistics more than 80%
of the ocean remains unexplored that's
most of the water covering the globe
completely unmapped and unobserved by
science it's a scary thought to dwell on
realizing that there's more water than
land on Earth and the sheer expanse of
that water is so large that we've been
unable to fully explore all of it just
think there are places in the ocean that
have never been seen by a human who
knows what's down there there if there
was ever a personification of fear of
the unknown the ocean could definitely
be it ancient shipwrecks sunk to the
ocean floor unknown sea creatures hiding
away from humanity and the general
isolation of the suffocating dark blue
the ocean swallows its victims with all
of these images that come to mind when
thinking about the vast and mysterious
depths of the sea and no one is more
familiar with nautical Mysteries than
the SCP Foundation today we'll be taking
a look at SCP 5007 the bass straight a
wave of oceanic anomalies fit to make
any seasoned sailor shiver in fear the
bass straight is an area of ocean
dividing Tasmania and the Australian
Mainland it's also the location of an
unusually high amount of disappearances
Sailors disappearing from their ships
fishermen leaving in the night and never
coming back even civilians disappearing
from the shores that connect to the
straight the foundation was aware of
these disappearances since 1858 but were
only able to craft theories about what
was causing them was it an anomalous
group of Interest hostile aerial
entities patrolling the skies above the
straight phenomenon associated with
unidentified flying objects what about
Subterranean anomalies weather patterns
or time dilation for nearly a century
the foundation was unable to determine
the cause of the high number of
disappearances in the bass straight and
then the phenomenon suddenly revealed
itself in 1980 on a beach connect
connected to the straight agent Taber an
operative of the SCP Foundation was
vacationing with his wife Mary and his
three young children the Taber family
was simply enjoying their day when they
saw what looked like balloons in the sky
they were approaching quickly and
naturally the family moved closer what
happened next was a whirlwind and those
balloons the family were so interested
in Lifted them up from the ground and
Carri them away agent tabner tried to
fight back but there was nothing he
could to do except report to the
foundation what had occurred and the
organization responded in full force the
foundation's research discovered that
reports of UFOs and lights in the sky
had coincided with many disappearances
in the straight and that this was a
pattern the search for the for lost
Taber family members had become a large-
scale investigation into unexplained
disappearances along the bass straight
and within 3 weeks it was determined
that these patterns were consistent
across the entirety of the Strait's
coastal region s some witnesses were
interviewed but the vast majority of
these abduction cases had no Witnesses
whatsoever of the minimal reports filed
the foundation was told that there were
lights in the sky and that appearance of
unidentified flying objects described as
having the appearances of balloons one
such witness interviewed was a man by
the name of Alan Stewart a witness who
was present during The Disappearance of
former Australian prime minister Harold
Holt whose disappearance the foundation
believed may have had a connection to
the bass straight anomalies during the
interview steuart claimed that Holt and
his family while voyaging on their yacht
decided to leave the boat and go for a
swim Holt turned to Stuart and asked him
if he could see the balloons around the
cliff Stuart had no idea what Holt was
talking about but Holt was insistent on
seeing them he swam deeper out into the
ocean saying that they weren't normal
balloons and that there was someone
inside of them Stuart and Hal's family
called out for him to come to shore but
he wouldn't listen Stuart tried to
rationalize what he saw next maybe it
was the current sweeping Holt away but
he couldn't lie to the foundation
interviewer Stuart saw Holt go further
and further out into the water and
suddenly the Prime Minister turned
around he began swimming in the opposite
direction and he was screaming suddenly
Holt was lifted from the sea and pulled
into the air by something emerging from
the clouds the foundation thanked
steuart for the interview and continued
their investigation 2 years later in
1982 Emergency Services receiv received
a large number of calls pertaining to
UFO sightings off the coast of Norman
Bay Victoria the foundation was quick to
respond alerting task forces and local
sites to prepare for an investigation
upon arriving to the scene they
confirmed the existence of multiple
entities that would later be documented
as SCP 5007 they evacuated civilians
from the area and successfully managed
to capture the creature which was later
transported to site 40 for containment
it was a sight to behold the The Entity
now designated SCP 57- S1 was a cluster
of human bodies fused between a grouping
of black tentacles of varying length
each tentacle was fused to the skin it
touched directly the stomachs of the
corpses were grossly swollen and
distorted to massive sizes to hold large
quantities of gases inside the Bucy of
which The Entity used to achieve a
passive flight across the entity's
surface were clusters of eyes and
bioluminescent glowing organs many of
the humanoid components of the corpses
appeared to have been removed and
misplaced across various parts of the
entity's body what's more is that the
foundation discovered that human
portions of SCP 5007 appeared somewhat
cognizant and aware of their situation
their vocalizations were incoherent and
barely understandable consisting of
gasping and whimpering but the corpses
were observed to implore other
individuals to approach them when
encountered SCP 57s behavior during
abduction scenarios was documented
during the initial containment event and
due to the foundation's painstaking
research a pattern was established
between all SCP 5007 encounters first
the victim would be alone or otherwise
vulnerable in a coastal location SCP
5007 haven't shown a preference for
weather be they clear or hostile Skies
but they have localized all of their
activity to the bass straight in small
coastal towns beaches or boats SCP 57
will then move towards the shore
stalking the victim before lowering its
tentacles and appendages to grab the
individual snatching them into the sky
an SCP 57 instance can even abduct
multiple people at once one event
observed had eight men from the decks of
a commercial fishing boat taken into the
sky in under 15 seconds once captured
SCP 57 instances will Dart across the
water at a high speed and take their
victims to an unknown location
discovering where as CP 5007 took their
victims became a top priority for the
foundation after extensive witness
interviews and compiling a database of
likely victims they determined that
there must be at least 16 instances of
SCP 57 unaccounted for personnel kept a
close watch on the coastlines and Waters
of the bass straight and equipped
various Marine task forces with research
vessels capable of tracking any
instances if they encountered them in
1985 the foundation's research efforts
paid off and several survey teams
operating in the area reported a
sighting of an extremely large SCP 5007
instance heading towards a coastal town
a mobile task force was sent to track
the entity the team observed The Entity
from afar as it stocked a private
fishing boat even from the distance
Foundation Personnel recognized the
likenesses of several missing persons as
faces of the corpses of SCP 5007 the
task force Captain had to remind his
team to keep it together claiming that
that they were not people but just parts
of the specimen but everyone secretly
knew the truth the fishing vessel was a
private one occupied by a small family
The Entity slowly approached and quickly
pulled a woman into the air the family
panicked and quickly tried to reach
cover for safety running into the Ship's
Cabin The Entity ran its tentacles along
the boat until it pulled the door open
snatching another two victims the task
force was enabled to help them as their
mission was to track the instance to its
origin point it was a horror to watch
the task force implanted a tracking
Beacon onto the entity and quietly
followed it out to sea over the next 4
hours they then discovered a large gray
Reef with several shipwrecks dotted
across it 13 SCP 57 instances floated
over the area some holding on to the
land Reef with their tentacles The
Entity dropped the abductees from the
fishing boat who were coerced by the
entities into diving into a massive pool
of water located in the center of the
reef one by one each abductee was pulled
below the surface by something lurking
in the pool all while the SCP 57
instances watched disgusted the task
force reported what they observed to the
main site and the reef would be
designated as SCP
57- the foundation's analysis of the
reef led to the discovery that The Rock
covering it seeped iron oxide from an
unknown source and the Rocks achieved
growth at an anomalously fast rate often
as little as 40 minutes all of the
wrecked ships and aircraft that washed
across the shore of the reef were
covered with a dark stone The Reef was
teeming with anomalous marine life
including SCP 5007 a red algae that fed
upon the freshly grown Rock Marine worms
capable of levitation spiders that lived
in silk Retreats underneath the
waterline small fish and giant organisms
resembling large clumps of kelp which
the foundation had previously documented
as SCP 4159 in a separate investigation
SCP 5007 often rested their tentacles on
the outcroppings of the wreath while
inactive but what caught the
foundation's attention the most was the
giant pit located in the reef center
unmanned exploration drones found that
it had a depth of at least 4,000 M and
water samples taken from the pit
revealed large quantities of human DNA
prehistoric bacteria and unknown
compounds that possess significant
life-preserving qualities when a being
was submerged in the comp compound they
were able to survive heavy injuries even
when fully surrounded by the liquid and
unable to breathe the foundation's
exploration of one of these shipwrecks
LED them to a journal most of it was
illegible due to water damage but one
passage survived located in the back of
the book it detailed the experience of
an unknown crew member of the ship
caught in a storm it reads Mosby spied
land ahead and the boy said that there
are giant balloons hanging over the
island we are all a feared but there is
not we can do but beat ourselves and
help for rescue should I be killed in
the crash I want my mates to give this
journal to my Mary might know I spent my
last thinking only of her the interior
of the ship contained human remains
inside but there were less skeletons
than the foundation would expect for a
ship of its size the location of the
rest of the bodies was unknown another
event related to SCP 5007 the foundation
documented involved Frederick valentic a
pilot engaged in a training flight over
the bass straet in 1978 Valenti's
disappearance was marked by his latest
communication with air traffic control
when he mistook an SCP 57 instance for
an unidentified aircraft it seems like
it's stationary what I'm doing right now
is orbiting and the thing is just
orbiting on top of me also it's got a
green light and sort of metallic like
it's all shiny on the outside shortly
after this Valenti's transmission was
interrupted by what was described as
metallic scraping sounds believed to be
the SCP 57 instance attacking the air
craft and jamming its propellers with
its mass after crashing into the reef it
was believed that valentic and his
aircraft were pulled beneath the surface
of the pit just as the abductees had
been prior the foundation decided to
construct a provisional secure research
facility on the reef they named it site
40- R and documented all returns and
departures of SCP 5007 they also set up
a series of containment procedures that
resulted in SCP 5007 returning with its
victims 83% less often than before the
site's construction but this was
short-lived in 2008 the site logged over
36 instances returning to the reef with
only two not having any fresh abductees
the instance's origins were unknown and
it was as if they appeared out of thin
air no other monitoring post had
documented their appearance or even
spotted them before they arrived at The
Reef it was years later in 2017 that the
foundation eventually was able to
successfully explore what was deep
inside the pit at the center of the reef
they already knew that there was a large
entity lurking beneath as evidence by
what happened to the victims of SCP 5007
that were later deposited inside the
pool all previous attempts to explore
the pool were met with failure as the
water pressure of the Pit's depths
caused all craft to collapse due to Ho
damage this time however they managed to
construct a high-tech submarine labeled
the scps Nautilus which was capable of
diving a maximum of 13 ,500 M underwater
they decided that a d-class Personnel
would be trained to man The submersible
and carry out the exploration the
mission was simple the Nautilus was to
dive to the bottom of the pit and to
describe the depth readings cameras and
microphones were equipped to the vessel
due to the depth remote viewing of the
footage was impossible instead the
foundation had to physically recollect
the vessel in order to view the footage
upon recovery some of the footage
suffered data corruption but what was
there shook the those who viewed it to
their core the footage showed the DCL
class's experience going deeper inside
the pit at first it seemed ordinary the
trench had a number of Rocky
outcroppings dotted with black yellow
Vines growing along the walls also
present were various marine life forms
such as the spiders or the fish going
deeper the sub observed an SCP 57
instance clinging to an outcropping
several tendrils emerging from the Pit's
depths were wrapped around the instance
and holding on to the entity as if it
were beaing from it another 16 SCP 57
instances were seen resting along the
walls each clinging to the outcropping
as the sub went deeper the d-class
remarked that there were dozens of plane
and shipwrecks but also well over 100 S
SCP 57 entities most of them were held
there by the black tendrils the d-class
as the sub went even deeper began
noticing human remains no short amount
of them either deep into the pit there
was a large mass of human remains
covering the entirety of the pit bodies
crushed and drained of blood but still
possessing intact eyes each individual
was still alive kept preserved by the
life sustaining compounds found within
the water the body stared at the sub and
moved attempting to grab onto the
vehicle the d-class swore they were
trying to say something mouthing words
to the camera of the sub as the sub
passed through the mass of bodies it
emerged into a completely dark black
clear ing at the bottom of the pit for a
second the declass thought he was safe
but then a large black tentacle rapidly
emerged from below and grabbed onto the
Nautilus dragging it even further Into
the Depths the d-class screamed and
panicked but there was nothing he could
do the tentacle possessed a large
cluster of eyes mouths and human heads
seemingly grafted onto its mass and then
there was another tentacle and then
another the Nautilus was pulled to the
bottom of the pool the D class's screams
were still heard heard even as the
picture cut out sometimes graphic body
altering images of the tentacles
features were visible on the screen but
most of the footage was indecipherable
after minutes of distorted corrupted
footage the Nautilus was seen again
rapidly ascending to the surface somehow
it had managed to escape the entity at
the bottom of the pit upon recovery of
The Craft it was found that the Nautilus
was covered in a thick organic coating
similar to a black slime mold but with
dozens of eyes growing from it the de
class inside showed severe psychological
damage and attempted to harm Foundation
Personnel they were terminated shortly
after due to being a danger to those
around them following review of the
footage the Nautilus was to be
dismantled and incinerated along with
the remains of the d-class a reinforced
containment seal was fitted over the pit
with the intention of keeping whatever
was down there isolated from the surface
but this was shortlived after the
containment seal was fitted site 40
underwent a massive Communications
blackout every device on site received
an email containing a single image of a
large eye taken from a security camera
the text beneath it simply read found
you some Personnel who viewed the email
underwent anomalous changes growing new
physical features such as eyes and other
various growths across their body the
entirety of site 40- went offline and
the foundation could not establish
contact in an emergency effort to do so
mobile task force gamma- 6 deep feeders
was sent to investigate the task Force's
assault on site 40- was a daring effort
as the majority of the site was
completely overtaken by tentacles
growths and anomalous alterations while
numerous altered Personnel were lost due
to the mission it was ultimately a
success some altered Personnel were able
to be saved through extensive surgery to
remove their anomalous growths and after
everything was said and done the site
was repaired and reconstructed without
incident following the site's repair
there has been little activity from The
Entity within the pit but the foundation
continued to keep an eye on the creature
and the ecosystem of the anomalous
marine life that live on the bass
straight never knowing what their next
move might be and always keeping in mind
the risk that comes with dealing with
these poorly understood entities violent
chaos unfolds across the shoreline huge
fleshy tendrils Slither out of the water
grabbing people who try to flee and drag
them into the depths as giant harpoons
made of bone whiz across the beach be
cutting down unfortunate sunbathers and
droves it is a terrifying Massacre but
you'd never in a million years be able
to guess its source on April 10th 2010
something strange began to happen in the
three Portlands now the anomalous
extradimensional city state that
overlaps with the locations of Portland
Oregon Portland Maine and the aisle of
Portland is no stranger to unusual
occurrences so it took the population a
little while to notice noticed that
something was happening but for some
unknown reason sailboats and motorboats
were beginning to vanish from the city
the disappearances occurred overnight
when there was no one around to witness
them but slowly the citizens began to
notice that their friends and family
members were going out in their
watercrafts and never returning home by
April 15th the civilians were becoming
noticeably concerned fearing the worst
on April 16th their worst fears were
confirmed when two local ghosts Anar
Ahmed and Greg Moore went for a
nighttime stroll along the harbor they
heard a sudden commotion and rushed to
the scene of the disturbance they
arrived just in time to see a living
individual being dragged into the watery
depths by a large veinlike tendril ammed
asked Greg to wait on land while he
ventured out into the water to look for
the victim unfortunately Ahmed never
came back and Greg took his story to the
three Portland's Police Department after
waiting a few days for the local maning
clam populace to migrate the FBI unusual
incidents unit mounted a formal
investigation on the morning of April
17th all of the missing Vehicles
suddenly reappeared this left the uiu
and the people of the city with even
more questions where had all the boats
gone why were they suddenly back and
what had happened to the missing people
who had not been returned along with
them on April 19th uiu agents dove into
the harbor to search for any unusual
activity and while they didn't spot
anything especially strange they did
discover that there were fewer animals
in the harbor than usual on April 21st
the threat that had been praying on the
citizens of three Portlands actually
made itself known at 11:19 a.m. 17 boats
moved away from the docks on their own
drifting up onto Shore though no one
could be seen captaining any of them as
the boats lined up they began to form a
wall blocking access to the water no one
one could get in or out civilians
watched in shock as the boats began to
warp and change before their eyes
growing thick masses of scales on their
surfaces sprouting Harpoon guns that
fired bony projectiles and slashing
veiny tendrils at anyone within reach
the citizens began to panic running in
every direction in an attempt to escape
the Monstrous boats but they were too
slow to evade the attacks and the boat
snatched them off of the shore and
yanked them aboard using their harpoons
to impale those who managed to run
farther than the tendrils could stretch
as the army of fleshy boats closed in
around the shore a tugboat broke through
the surface of the water unlike the rest
of the boats it had a noticeable hole in
its Hull and was missing its wheelhouse
at an unnaturally quick Pace the tugboat
began to advance onto land using its
tendrils to drag itself along the shore
and into the more populous part of town
it grabbed civilians at random absorbing
their blood into its metallic surface as
it went suddenly it spotted Albert ISAT
a noted member of the Church of the
broken God and began to focus its attack
on him but before the tugboat monster
could reach ISAT a city security gollem
interfered sadly though the gollem put
up a valiant fight the anomaly was able
to destroy it by Falling onto it again
and again until the gollem was no longer
able to get back up there are few
creatures that would survive having a
boat drop itself on top of them
repeatedly and sadly the security Golem
was not one of them with the Golem out
of the way the boat continued to drag
itself through the streets wildly
crashing through the side of a local
restaurant where its owner an entity
known as the GRL was in the middle of a
busy brunch service at the sight of the
invading watercraft the GRL set down his
pitch of bottomless mimosas wiped his
hands on his apron and grabbed his
trusty dual wield swords from under
underneath the counter he kept them
there in case someone attempted to dine
and dash but he figured they would do
just fine against a blood drinking
Tugboat while the GRL kept the tugboat
busy uiu forces were able to break
through the barricade of boats for a
brief period of time allowing more
security Golems to enter the area as
well as allowing more citizens to escape
unfortunately this little victory was
shortlived as further unforeseen Horrors
drudged themselves up from the deep the
reanimated corpses of various species
native to the harbor began to crawl out
of the water surrounding the GRL and
allowing the tugboat to escape the fight
as it made its way back to the harbor
every boat it passed attempted to toss
bodies onto the tugboat covering it in
fresh blood slowly but surely the damage
to the tugboat began to repair itself
once the boat had regained its strength
it set its sights on a previously
untouched cargo ship an observing uiu
officer determined that the boat was
somehow attempting to convert the cargo
ship to transform it into another one of
its fleshy allies but before the
transformation could take place a cargo
crate broke open spilling over 1,000
hard tack crackers suddenly the tugboat
stopped everything that it was doing it
took one tendril and began to count each
individual cracker that had Spilled Out
well the tugboat was distracted with its
task a citizen offered the uiu use of
their rare Metals Cannonball collection
in the fight to apprehend the aggressive
boat one particular Cannonball made from
electrum was able to puncture the hole
of one of the infected ships rendering
it motionless they were elated to have
found a weapon that worked against these
boats while the tugboat continued to
count the remaining towns people
gathered all of the electrum they could
find and began to fight back against the
boats one by one the boats sank and all
the while the tugboat continued to count
in the meantime uiu officers managed to
free the GRL from his zombie attackers
they presented him with an electrum
Cannonball which he proceeded to punch
finger holes into and wield like a
bowling ball then the GRL had a score to
settle no one whether human ghost or
tugboat was going to mess with his
brunch the grur barreled towards the
harbor grabbed hold of the still
distracted Tugboat and punched it hard
with his Cannonball fist if the tugboat
could breathe the punch would have
knocked the air out of its lungs the
grul then threw the tugboat out of the
water and continued The Savage beating
before preparing to destroy the battered
vehicle once and for all he lifted it up
into the air jumped up to follow it and
hit it with so much force that the
tugboat careened through the air
colliding with a portal that had
transported it to the aisle of Portland
luckily this portal could only be
unlocked via a high-speed impact from a
water-based vehicle speaking of luck an
SCP Foundation team was returning to the
aisle from a failed mission just as the
anomalous boat appeared in their reality
the object was knocked unconscious by
the impact of its travel and the beating
from the GRL and in its incapacitated
state it was transported to a nearby
Foundation site there it was contained
and given the designation of SCP
6426 due to its anomalous traits
including the consumption of blood a
talent for hypnosis and a compulsive
counting habit it was also given the
nickname The Vampire boat SCP 6426 is a
ker class Sapient hostile entity that in
an inactive State Bears the appearance
of a harbor Tugboat in a constant state
of rust and degradation any blood or
organs containing blood that come into
contact with the boat will be absorbed
through the metal causing the
degradation to visibly improve as a
result the most effective blood appears
to come from humans sitations and a few
specific species of
salti the entity does not only use the
absorb blood to improve its appearance
but but is also capable of using it to
create organic additions to its body
including the vein-like tendrils spotted
in the three Portlands Cognito hazardous
eyes attached to bending eye stocks
Harpoon guns and cannons capable of
firing ammunition made from anomalous
species of barnacles these Barnacles are
capable of reanimating dead tissue on
contact and SCP 6426 frequently uses
them to create instances of SCP
6426 C masses of reanimated tissue that
the boat uses to Aid in its attacks or
self-defense SCP 6426 uses its tendrils
to grab prey and drag them towards
itself but the tendrils serve an
additional purpose as well each of the
tendrils has a mouth on the tip similar
in structure to that of the North
American medicinal leech when the
tendril has made contact with its prey
the mouth will then bite into the spinal
column of the creature causing its brain
function to cease as its canines grow
long and Hollow hard scales form on
their skin and their muscle mass and
bone density increase once they have
been transformed in this way organisms
taken by SCP 6426 are designated SCP
6426 daa these instances are used to the
entity's advantage helping it to extract
blood from victims at a distance as well
as providing an additional line of
defense and offense in the event that
SCP 6426 encounters another watercraft
it is able to use SCP
6426 to convert the vehicle into an
instance of SCP 6426 DB these converted
boats are similar to SCP 6426 and are
able to function on their own however
they are unable to produce their own ice
stocks or cannons unable to create SCP
6426 daa instances and do not appear to
be as intelligent as their creator in
the early days of its containment the
exact nature of the anomaly's
intelligence was the subject of debate
amongst the research staff however on
one specific occasion the foundation was
able to establish a line of direct
communication with SCP
6426 and conduct the first and so far
the only interview with the vampiric
tugboat the inciting incident occurred
when the arrival of the foundation's
latest hard tax shipment was delayed
leaving the boat with nothing to count
and nothing to keep it occupied freed
from the bounds of counting it managed
to escape and grab hold of several
foundations staff members with its
tendrils after Chasing the boat through
the site guards were able to Corner it
prompting the boat to absorb the bodies
it had taken and used the organic
material to produce a siren that emitted
the sound of a human voice it is through
this siren that as CP 6426 responded to
interview questions using the voice of
one of its victims Junior researcher
sjad Williamson in spite of his protests
was selected to conduct the interview
his fellow staff members refused to take
no for an answer and as the newest hire
the unpleasant job fell on his shoulders
much to everyone's surprise the anomaly
began the conversation rather politely
saying I am so sorry I thought you were
those self-righteous lunatics from the
church I apologize profusely for any
trouble I may have caused and I want to
point out I fully support your mission
yes our first line of defense against
the undersea Menace I am more than
willing to punch sharks s patience yes
right how rude of me yes Dr Williamson's
first question concerned SCP 6426
apparent intended victim back in three
Portlands Albert ISAT SCP 6426 responded
Albert his first name is really
Albert well what other relationship is
there to say besides the Hunter and the
hunted Admiral ISAT is a ruthless Man
known for terrorizing and slaughtering
people like me he was leading a search
party of those barbaric Niles intending
to gut me like a seal what do you mean
people like you Dr Williamson inquired
freethinkers of course people who are
unafraid to break from the mold to carve
their own path in life instead of
following the predetermined route set by
that ignorant check valve the church is
built upon a foundation of lies no one's
really a petty officer on this ship what
just cabin boys stumbling around in the
dark as we follow the commands of an
off-hand
Co if you want real power real Freedom
all you have to do is listen for the
call of the Beast open the portal and
he'll squeeze you right
through Dr Williamson feeling rather in
over his head attempted to convince one
of his colleagues to take over when he
refused however Dr Williamson continued
um could you explicate your activities
within the harbor and how you arrived
there well after I got the bans off my
trail I found a cave to hide in I was
forced to hide in yes forced to hide
deep in the cave which turned out to be
a tunnel surprisingly the tunnel led to
some Coastal Community where I took
Refuge licking my wounds in the safety
of the depths as o Zealot sto the
surface I spent my time preparing
Gathering the strength necessary to face
them once more until I was ambushed
assaulted within my Hideout by a bat
swine I fought for my life as I was
forced out into the open and descended
upon by a manner of monsters and freaks
of this orchestrated by that scumbag
eard I was beaten within an inch of my
life before I'm not quite sure what
happened after that I believe I was
knocked on conscious you'll have to
Illuminate Me on how I came to be in
your custody at this point the interview
began to Veer in an odd Direction the
boat expressed confusion about the
nature of Williamson's questions
specifically how little they related to
the subject of sharks and punching them
it was at this point that the site
director sought guidance from the multi
Department a researcher there informed
Williamson about the confusion SCP 6426
had mistaken the SCP Foundation for
another organization the shark punching
Center Dr Williamson resumed the
interview prepared to play along and
keep the boat comfortable unfortunately
Williamson was a terrible liar yes we
are the shark punching Center we will
determine if you are a suitable
candidate to carry out the mission to
search punch and contain sh I mean
cations this verbal misstep caused SCP
6426 to become suspicious after a moment
it pieced together the truth and began
to throw itself against the wall in a
desperate attempt to escape it was
apprehended by security guards who
impaled it with a naval RAM and returned
the watercraft to its containment cell
the exact reason for its apparent fear
and hatred of the foundation is
currently unknown and the boat has made
no attempt to speak since currently SCP
6426 is kept in a 39 MX 39 m x 50 m
containment chamber beneath the chamber
there is an artificial lava tube the
tugboat has a naval Ram through its Hull
and engine holding it in place this Ram
is checked daily for signs of
degradation as it is the primary force
keeping the anomaly immobile if the ram
is ever removed or damaged somehow a
fail safe system will activate releasing
100 hard attack crackers and two pieces
of electrum into the containment chamber
this is intended to keep the tugboat
occupied until the naval Rod can be
replaced if for some reason the naval
Rod fails and the boat runs out of heart
attack to count while there will be
nowhere on water or land that that we
can hide if you've ever taken a vacation
to one of the many islands of Greece
then you'll know why the likes of cre
Lesbos and Corfu are famous for their
beautiful beaches but there is one beach
in particular tucked away in a corner of
an unknown Island that you might think
twice about visiting why well the same
reasons that this place happens to be a
site of great interest for thep
foundation also tend to drive tourists
away today we're talking about SCP
2217 the strange anomalous happenings
that have taken place there and how it
links to none other than one of the
foundations most infamous groups of
interest at first glance SCP 2217 is an
ordinary uninteresting Beach just
another pretty picturesque view on a
Greek island it looks like the kind of
place that would be perfect for a
romantic walk at Sunset but we wouldn't
recommend it although you wouldn't know
just from looking at it the sand that
this beach is composed of has some
pretty peculiar properties it contains
the ordinary non-anomalous things you'd
find in sand anywhere else in the world
normal levels of silicates and calcium
compounds but the beach also possesses a
high concentration of cationic metallic
particles these tiny almost microscopic
metal fragments somehow hold an
electrical charge despite being grounded
so it's a beach with partially metal
sand nothing too unusual there right
wrong
the metallic particles within the sand
seem to have a profound effect on the
natural environment around SCP
227 for one the metal content of the
beach influences the weather increasing
the number of lightning strikes that hit
the shore the metals draw the static
electricity in the atmosphere this along
with other weather conditions and
natural processes that take place at SCP
2217 also have a far more obvious
anomalous effect lightning rain even
fish washed up and decaying on the
shoreline have all caused various
artificial structures and devices to
rise from the beach which have all been
designated by the foundation as SCP 221
2017-1 among the Creations found on the
beach in the wake of lightning strikes
are a number of different forms of
Machinery these have included simple
clocks and other time pieces to
complicated automatons these machines
have no notable anomalous properties as
far as the SCP Foundation is found apart
from the way they came to be and they
are otherwise fully functional also
discovered at SCP 227 was jewelry
seeming to be made of discarded waste
that washed up on the beach in the tide
resembling bears and other recurring
motifs of a certain religion these
articles of jewelry have been made using
everything from old light bulbs to holes
of ships and even fish and animal bones
most notably however was the appearance
of a city or rather a model of a city
that was created at the beach and was
then referred to as SCP
22171 there's a cliff located on SCP
2217 and if one is to swim through an
underwater entrance they will find
themselves inside a grotto there somehow
carved by tital erosion of the rock is a
recreation of an ancient Greek city
although the geographical features of
the model seem to resemble an area near
Lake Bal in southern Siberia the city
Bears more of the same religious
iconography to the jewelry that can
often be found on the beach but which
religion the same one that considers SCP
2217 to be a site of holy importance the
Church of the broken God now some
important context to make note of for
any who are unaware the Church of the
broken God is a religious organization
that the SCP Foundation has had a number
of encounters with over the years
members of the church share in their
belief that biological flesh B life is
inherently wrong an Abomination even
evil this religion worships
mechanization the process of making
something or someone more mechanical in
nature according to the beliefs of the
church there were two gods yabo and
mechain who created Humanity together
yabo was the god of Flesh and animal
Instinct granting human bodies meanwhile
the god of machine and intellect mechain
blessed man with the power of free
thought
as humankind developed its civilizations
by building machines yalalo became
enraged that they were ignoring the
instincts she had bestowed upon them she
endeavored to destroy the creations of
man in an attempt to revert them to the
animal she had intended them to be as
the church's Legend goes mckain acted as
Humanity's Savior and tried desperately
to stop yabo the god of machine
shattered himself transforming his body
into a number of pieces to form a cage
for his fellow God fragments of mechain
rained down on planet Earth now the
Church of the broken God believes it is
their duty to recover these missing
parts and put their savior back together
within the religion of the Church of the
broken God there exists a splinter
faction that broke away from the main
church this group referred to as the
broken church are the ones that regard
SCP 2217 so highly considering it to be
a holy sight according to a piece of
scripture from their religion the broken
Church believes the beach to be Main's
Workshop the book of writs describes the
legend of a boy looking out at the ocean
with his family and seeing fire rain
down on the shore sent from God or
mechain to the church meccan apparently
proclaimed that the beach was his
Workshop where he made Many Wonders the
lightning is my hammer the Earth my
Anvil the sand my Ingot mckain explained
to the boy so the legend goes and
invited the child into his Workshop the
broken God brought his hammer down on
the boy but instead of killing him
marked him as the first of the religion
the broken church now follows in 2014
the SCP Foundation recorded an
earthquake taking place at SCP
2217 with The Grotto containing the
model of the ancient Greek city at the
epicenter sending a robotic probe Into
The Grotto to assess the damage only to
find a surprising change that had
occurred for the first time time there
were a number of humanoid figures seen
within SCP
22171 and worse still they were under
attack within the model City what
appeared to be a number of individuals
infected with SCP 610 were ransacking
buildings devouring and infecting the
other humanoid figures also known as the
flesh that hates scp160 is a contagious
skin disease it is usually transmitted
by direct skin-to-skin contact and
anyone that is infected with It suffers
a horrific mutation that transforms them
into fleshy inhuman
monstrosities these infected creatures
will attack and infect anyone nearby
that isn't also carrying SCP 610
interestingly the disease was first
discovered to be localized to a small
area in Siberia not dissimilar to the
area that the SCP 2217 A1 model
resembled According to some sources SCP
610 is the flesh described by those
following the religion of sarcasm a cult
that worships flesh and disease sarcasm
is a sect that directly opposes and
antagonizes the Machine revering Church
of the broken God 3 years after the
earthquake members of the broken Church
staged an attack on the beach hoping to
reclaim SCP 2217 for their religion at
the time the SCP Foundation had closed
off the area to the public under the
cover story that SCP 2217 was private
private property they had been hoping to
predict the lightning strikes that
caused the anomalous devices to form on
the beach instead the foundation had to
repel the broken Church's attackers any
way they could however as the lightning
began to strike again members of
foundation Personnel that found
themselves caught in it seemed to change
sides all stating that God needs to be
reassembled only a year later in 2018
another group of broken Church zealots
stormed the beach and the foundation
Outpost located there this time the
church seemed to have gained further
reinforcements specifically members of
other groups of interest in particular
some belonging to the Church of
maxwellism and the cogwork Orthodox
Church both of which were also Splinter
groups of the Church of the broken God
the cogwork Orthodox Church arose during
the Industrial Revolution believing that
adding mechanical parts to their own
bodies offered greater understanding of
meain and brought them closer to their
God Max ual ISM in a similar vein had
another interpretation of the church's
core beliefs favoring smaller more
advanced cybernetic implants the Church
of maxwellism sought to modify their
brains to become a collective
Consciousness and commune with McCain
despite a lot of pre-existing animosity
between the three core Splinter groups
of the church they were able to
successfully capture SCP
2217 the three factions sent a video
message to the foundation proclaiming
the importance of their mission oh
disassemblers who call themselves a
foundation what are you a foundation for
if you are a foundation for life then
you will let us keep this land for the
flesh is coming and only we can stop it
we need to bring our God back together
immediately or else you will all perish
and now it is time if you are a
foundation for life you will not let
this happen you will let us defeat the
flesh several more messages were sent to
the foundation demanding the release of
various scps with connection to the
broken God you see there could
potentially be hundreds of pieces needed
to rebuild mechain so he can lead the
church to glory and defeat yalah a
number of these pieces happen to be
cataloged scps and the foundation is
either aware of or has in containment
these include SCP 882 or his broken
heart to the church SCP 271 his broken
gift SCP 8113 his Broken Eyes SCP 1139
his broken tongue SCP 635 his broken
mind and finally his broken blood which
refers to SCP
27 with the beach under the control of
the Church of the broken God any
foundation Personnel Left Alive on SCP
2217 defected and joined the church in
order to retake the beach and
reestablish containment the foundation
was forced to do something that they
only do in the most dire of
circumstances ask for help together with
the horizon initiative and Global occult
Coalition the SCP Foundation established
what it called the triumvirate a Joint
Task Force in 2019 another earthquake
was detected this time in Lake ball
Siberia where SCP 610 was contained not
long after infected individuals were
reported to be attacking Foundation
forces in the area causing heavy
casualties but then an unlikely event
took place members of the Church of the
broken God appeared their bodies
augmented with Machinery these zealots
that had fought the foundation for
control of SCP 2217 were now coming to
its Aid to repel SCP 610 according to
them God or rather mecan had told them
to come to assist the foundation using a
large-scale electrical discharge
instances of the SCP 610 contagion were
eradicated but this discharge seemed to
have originated from the same island
where SCP 2217 was found following this
incident Robert buero the leader of the
broken Church sent a video message to
the leaders of the triber including the
05 Council the director of the global
coath Coalition and the Horizon
initiatives tribunal in his message
buero stated it's not too late you know
this is our world as well we both want
the flesh to end and we can help you we
can help each other come to the Anvil we
will talk and we can save this world the
Church of the broken God its Splinter
groups United to take SCP 2217 for their
religion were now extending an olive
branch to the foundation and its allies
all in the name of protecting the world
shortly after the foundation Global cult
Coalition and Horizon initiative began
working collaboratively with the Church
of the broken God to prepare for an XK
class scenario retaking control of the
SCP 2217 Beach for now the foundation
intends to revoke this current
Arrangement after the dangerous scenario
has been averted but perhaps McCain's
Workshop will provide vital in
reassembling the broken God and saving
Humanity should yal deach ever return to
exact her terrible Revenge now go check
out SCP 001 the broken God or boros
cycle at SCP 1594 Miss J's whiz kid
Schoolhouse for more technological scps